latex is a type setting system for
creating professional looking documents
commonly used in Academia and scientific
publishing with the focus on content
rather than appearance Michelle crummel
is your instructor in this latex course
for beginners
she is an experienced teacher with
multiple mathematics degrees
welcome I'm Michelle crummell and in
this video I'm going to show you how to
get started using latex latex is a
document markup language and it's used
to create professional looking documents
with consistent formatting it's
especially useful if you're typesetting
mathematical notation so it's great if
you're writing a paper that contains
mathematics if you're creating tests and
quizzes or typing up homework
assignments I use it for other things
too like creating slide presentations
and even writing letters of
recommendations it has many many uses
as a teacher some of the main reasons I
prefer using latex over word processors
besides just how professional it the
output looks is that latex is
cross-platform it's backwards compatible
it produces PDF files that are small and
can be opened on any device and it's
free open source and highly customizable
but before you get started creating your
own latex documents you have a decision
to make do you want to work and store
your files online or offline
the advantages of working online are
that you don't have to download install
or update any software onto your
computer so you can get started right
away you can even work collaboratively
in real time using shared documents
the advantages of working offline on the
other hand are that you have complete
control over how you organize and store
your files and you don't need an
internet connection to work on your
files
both options work really well it just
depends what's going to be best for you
so I'm going to start by showing you how
to work online because for a beginner
that's probably the fastest and easiest
way to get started
so to work online we're going to use a
website called overleaf so you can just
do a Google search for overleaf or you
can go right to overleaf.com now I
already have an account set up so when I
went to overleaf.com it automatically
logged me in but if this is your first
time visiting overleaf you will want to
create an account and you can do that
using an email address so because I
don't have any files created so far in
my account this is the screen I'm seeing
when I log in once you create at least
one Tech file you're going to see a
different screen when you first log in
and you'll see a list of all of your
files but for now we're going to click
on create first project and we want a
blank project and you're going to have
to come up with a name for your project
I'm just going to call this tutorial one
so when we create a new project in
overleaf it's automatically going to
populate some code for us this is really
really just the basics here and we can
see that we have sort of three Windows
here on the far left this is going to
show us our file structure the name of
our Tech file is main.tech and then in
the middle here we have the place where
we're going to be typing our code and
then over on the right we have our PDF
output so we can see what our final
document is going to look like
so just a couple of things to point out
here when you make any changes to the
code and you want to see what they look
like in the output you are going to have
to click recompile
when you make changes over here it's not
going to automatically update on the
right you do have to hit recompile and
generally if you're not working in
overleaf you're not going to get this
sort of starter template here you're
just going to have an empty slate to
work with now if I try and compile right
now I'm probably going to get an error
because there is no code let's see what
happens
yeah so it's not giving us just a blank
PDF it's actually coming back with an
error and saying that it can't compile
the code and that is of course because
we don't have any code
so let's just do some really basic
code in here in overleaf and then I'm
going to switch over and show you how
you can work offline that's my preferred
method and that's what I'm going to be
using in my future tutorials
so to start our document we're going to
hit backslash and we want to make sure
that we are always using the backslash
and not the forward slash so the
backslash is starting our Command and
then I want document class now as I
start typing document class you can see
that it's kind of guessing what I'm
going to be typing and I can now just
click on that to complete the command or
I could have just continued typing it
out with my keyboard so we have document
class then we have a pair of square
brackets followed by a pair of curly
brackets and we have to type something
in these brackets this is part of the
code so in the curly brackets at the end
we're going to Define what kind of class
that we're using and for us it's going
to be an article
now that doesn't mean we're writing an
article like a newspaper article but
that is just the name of the class the
type of document that we are creating
there are other document classes that
you can use for example if we had
entered Beamer there we would be
creating slides almost like a PowerPoint
presentation
if we typed exam there then we have a
different type of class where that I use
for creating tests and quizzes
but most of the time
I use article now the square brackets
these are for optional arguments so I
could actually delete the square
brackets and not use them at all I could
even just leave them there blank with
nothing inside but here we can type some
options so one of the things that we can
type in here is the font size so I think
the default is 10 point I'm not sure I
always use 11 points so now I can't even
remember now what the default is but if
we want to use 11 Point instead of 10
point or 12 point then we can type that
the PT stands for point and that's going
to change our font size now if I try
compiling right now I have some code
here right I suspect I'm still going to
get an error
yeah I'm still getting error because I
haven't really started my document yet
there's no real content in here so
that's like the bare minimum that you
need to declare before you actually
begin your document the next thing we're
going to type is backslash begin
and then in curly brackets
document so again it's anticipating what
I want I can just hit enter
and it will fill in for me or I could
have continued to type it out on my
keyboard now when I hit enter notice not
only did it give me begin document but
it also gave me end document so this is
a command that comes in a pair it's got
a begin and an end if you type backslash
begin document and you forget to type
backslash end document your file will
not compile so it knows when it sees a
begin to be looking for a matching end
so we want to make sure and do that and
it's a good idea to go ahead and just
type the ending command and then move
your cursor back in between and type the
rest of your content so you don't forget
and let's do just something really basic
like hello
and I'm going to compile recompile and
see what we get
so we do have something now something on
the screen you can see that not
everything I typed in the code is
showing up on the screen the commands
aren't going to show up but the text
itself is and we can use the color
coding to kind of give us an indication
of what's what so the text that I typed
is colored black whereas the commands
the backslash document class backslash
begin backslash end those are blue so we
can distinguish between them
so let's type a little bit more than
that this is my first
latex document
and recompile it's a good idea to
compile frequently because if you wait
for too long before you compile you may
end up with five or six errors and then
it's very difficult to go back and
figure out exactly where the errors
happened you know it ideally you would
only want you know one error to deal
with at a time so it's it is a good idea
to compile frequently and that way you
can catch any errors right when they
when they happen
all right so hello this is my first
latex document and you may have noticed
if you've been kind of looking at things
online that the the word latex is often
typeset in a very particular way it's
kind of got a special font if you will
to make it look a certain way and we can
very easily accomplish that here by
putting a backslash in front of latex
now you do have to spell it exactly how
I spelled it with a capital l a
lowercase a a capital t a lowercase e
and a capital x so let's recompile and
see what happens
now actually this doesn't look great I
mean it's nice that uh the word latex is
typeset correctly but there's no space
between the X and the word document so
to get the space in there I'm going to
just put another backslash at the end of
that command
okay and that fixed that right up
now you might be wondering why it's
spelled l-a-t-e-x and I keep saying
latex and not latex the letter at the
end of the word is actually not an X
it's actually the Greek letter Chi and
the Greek letter Chi sounds more like a
k than it does an X it doesn't sound
exactly like a k but that's the closest
I would say letter in our alphabet to
what it sounds like so it's a it's like
a hard k sound it's not an X sound at
the end a lot of people say latex
instead of latex both are correct it's
just a matter of preference
so there we are which is just a really
basic document that we've gotten started
here and I do want to do a little bit
more with this to explain
especially like how line breaks and some
very basic format formatting works but
I'm going to go ahead and switch over
now to working offline and show you how
to do that if you have
lots of latex files like I do I mean I
have thousands and thousands of latex
files that I create
um I prefer to be able to store them on
my hard drive if I'm working an overleaf
everything kind of gets let me go ahead
and show you before we leave I'm going
to hit this up Arrow to go back to kind
of this
main screen here and if I list all my
projects I only have this one that I
created tutorial one
but as I start creating more projects
you're just going to see a long list of
files here I like to be able to put
things in folders and subfolders and in
some cases Sub sub folders and move
things around on my computer to store
things the way that I want so that's the
one downside I personally find with
using overleaf is just the file
structure and how you store and find
things now you can tag your files which
does allow you to filter things and make
it easier so instead of having a list of
100 files you know maybe you can narrow
it down by by tags and that does help a
bit so if you do want to work offline
you are going to need to install some
software on your computer and there are
two pieces of software that you need to
create latex documents you need a latex
distribution and then you need a text
editor so the latex distribution is what
is going to turn your code into some
kind of output file like a PDF file the
text editor is just what you use to type
the code and there are all kinds of text
editors right you can even just use
notepad something really basic as a text
editor to type your code it's important
when you're installing these two pieces
of software that you do so in the
correct order install the distribution
first you need to install your latex
distribution first so I get quite a few
comments people asking for help and
saying you know they're they're trying
to compile their first file and it's not
working they're getting errors it's
really important that you install your
distribution first so that's up and
running and then install your text
editor and try using your text editor
okay so what you what are you what
should you install where there's lots
and lots of options and then your
options are going to be different based
on whether you are a Windows PC user or
a Mac OS user so if you have a Windows
computer then my recommendation is to
install mictec as your latex
distribution you're going to do that
first
and then to install tech maker as your
text editor now mid Tech when you
install it does come bundled with its
own text editor and you can use that I
just don't find it as user friendly as
tech maker tech maker is so wonderful
for people who are starting out with all
of the nice options and and the way that
it color codes things and the way that
you can create macros I really love
techmaker and even though I'm not a
beginner I that's still my go-to program
for editing latex code
if you are a Mac User I'm a Mac User
then you want to install Mac Tech for
your latex distribution and tech maker
for your text editor okay so again
please install your distribution first
so that's either mctech or Mac Tech and
then once that is installed you can
install the text editor and all of this
is absolutely free to download install
and use
so here I am in tech maker right so
because I'm on a Mac I've got Mac Tech
installed as my latex distribution now
Mac Tech is not something that you would
ever like click on and open it just
works in the background the text edit
editor is what you're going to interface
with so I don't have to worry about Mac
Tech or creating a shortcut um you know
to it or anything like that you can once
you have it installed and it's working
you can just completely ignore it but
tech maker my text editor is what I'm
going to use to create my documents and
type my code
so right now I'm in techmaker now I this
isn't a fresh install so I'm not sure
that my screen looks exactly what like
what you will see when you first log in
it's possible that
um
that you have
see this structure thing turned on here
uh I'm just clicking through some of
these other right now what I'm seeing
looks more like what we saw in overleaf
where you've got some
um information over here I mean there's
nothing here yet because we haven't
created anything
but some file structure information over
here and then in the middle is where we
will be typing our code and then over
here on the right is where we will be
viewing our PDF
but to save on some screen space I
really don't need to see the structure
tag tab
so I'm going to turn that off and then
my messages log I mean it's I can turn
it off it's going to automatically come
back up when I compile so it's not that
important the PDF viewer I do want to be
able to see my PDFs as I work
so I will leave that showing now we
don't see anything because we we're not
actually working in a file at the moment
so the first thing we're going to do
here is to create a file actually the
first thing we should do is look at our
preferences and and make sure that we
have some good options selected so I'm
going to go into tech maker sorry that's
just a cut off you can't see that but if
you go to your your menu here click on
tech maker and preferences and I think
it's different on the Mac version
if you are on a Windows PC you might
have to go to like preferences or
options but somewhere in here you should
be able to pull up the window that I'm
seeing right now so it might be called
options or it might be called
preferences based on whether you have
the Mac version or the windows version
okay so what in this first screen for
this commands tab you want to make sure
that you have this box checked right
here PDF viewer we want to embed the PDF
that's what's going to allow us to see
the PDF on the right and the code on the
left so we want to check that box
I'm using my built-in viewer to view the
PDFs
and then you also want to check this box
down here launch the clean tool when
exiting techmaker that's really useful
when you create latex documents and you
close your document
you're going to see a lot of files that
are created in that process you have
your Tech file you have your PDF file
and you have log files and a bunch of
other files and really the only ones
that you are going to need
are the tech file which is you know your
source code and then your PDF your
output so just those two files so if you
click launch the clean tool it will
automatically delete all of those like
helper files and make your just your
folder structure and navigation so much
easier to to deal with
if we go to quick build you want to make
sure that you've selected PDF latex view
PDFs if your intention is to create PDF
files
under editor you can change some of
these options if you like I normally
don't have my font size this large but
for the purposes of the video I want you
to be able to see what I'm typing more
clearly so I increased that I usually
have it about 16. word wrapping I I
recommend that you do keep that on and
completion if you like that that's if
you start to type a command it's going
to suggest what it thinks that you're
trying to type so you can just hit enter
and then show line numbers is also
really helpful
because when you get error messages
sometimes you can look at the line
number and go right to that line number
and try and figure out what the error is
back up your document every 10 minutes
you can turn that on if you like I I
don't have any particular reason why I
did not have it turned on
let's see everything else looks pretty
good shortcuts these are just keyboard
shortcuts that that you probably don't
want to worry about when you're first
starting out but you might want to take
a look at those as you get more
comfortable with this
okay so let's create our first document
now you do have to actually create a
document
so I'm going to click on new here or you
can use the menu and click on file new
now this new document here it says
Untitled we haven't saved it yet so I
haven't actually created anything and
even if I type some code and try and
compile it I'm going to get an error
message you have to save the file first
name it and save it first before you're
going to be able to compile it so don't
skip that step because that can be
frustrating you're wondering why this is
not working you actually have to save
the die it's not enough just to say I'm
here I'm creating a new file you
actually have to save it
so file let's save this
and I'm just going to call this tutorial
one
tutorial 01 now one thing I want to
stress here is that you should never use
spaces in your file names for your Tech
files don't use spaces if you don't like
your words all running together you can
do something like a hyphen hyphens are
fine if you want to do that you can do
an underscore if you want to do that
like if you have want to put multiple
words in your title
I usually do an underscore when I name
my files but do not use a space so I'll
just keep the underscore in here and the
file extension is going to be dot Tech
but that's you know that's going to
happen by default so I don't really have
to type the dot Tech when I am naming
that so I'm going to just open up that
folder and show you what I've just
created
okay here we go so this is my file that
I just created
tutorial01.tech and you can see that
there aren't any other files in this
folder
so let's go ahead and recreate just the
basic code that we had when we were
using overleaf so backslash document
class and I'm going to fill that in I
think we had 11 points
it's an article
and then backslash begin documents
and we have our end document and then we
said hello
this is my first
latex
document
now to compile this we see that we don't
have a recompile button like we did in
overleaf I'm going to click on this
Arrow
to compile the code and it used to be I
just clicked on this arrow and it would
run both of these I'm not sure what my
issue is at the moment but it's it's
making me click both arrows like over
here to compile and then here to view
the PDF this isn't generally the way I
do it the way I generally do it is to
just hit F1 on the keyboard so as I'm
working throughout these tutorials if
you wonder like how how is it seem to be
refreshing so quickly you didn't see me
come up here and press on the Arrow it's
because I just hit F1 on my keyboard
that's a really fast way to do it
oh wait I think I do know why that's not
working quite right so the PDF latex
will compile the code and then view PDF
is going to is going to refresh the PDF
so we can view it over here but if I
want to do both of those things at once
what I actually want to select here is
quick build so that when I click on this
Arrow it's going to
do whatever I have saved in quick build
and if we go back to our preferences
quick build is right here I have PDF
latex view PDF in my quick build so when
I choose quick build it's going to do
both of those two things
and then while we're in here I'm going
to go ahead and uncheck this backup
every 10 minutes and the reason I'm
going to uncheck that is because if I
leave that on then not only am I going
to be creating a tech file and a PDF but
I'm also going to be creating a back Bak
file and I just don't want to have all
of that stuff in my folders it's
absolutely not a big deal if you want to
leave it on there and have backup files
in your folders that is perfectly fine
so here's what we have so far hello this
is my first latex document and we can
fit this to the width so it's a little
easier to see we can you know zoom in or
outfit it to a full page
and so I'm going to continue to work in
tech maker but if you are more
comfortable working in overleaf you
don't want to hassle with trying to get
the software installed and up and
running that is perfectly okay you can
still type the same code that I'm typing
and your output should look exactly the
same
I'm gonna go back to fit width so we
have we can see this a little bit better
it's not too small on your screen
and let's move on so I have you know one
line typed here next I want to type a
little bit of math so I'm going to say a
rectangle it has side lengths of X Plus
1 and X plus three so let me hit return
and type that out
[Music]
and because this is in a sentence I know
that it would look better
if I used parentheses around the X Plus
1 and the X plus 3 so let me do that
and let's compile and see how that looks
so again you can use the arrows up here
I'm just going to hit F1 on my keyboard
and this is what we have now this might
look okay to you it doesn't look that
great to me
there's a couple things I want to point
out the first thing you might notice if
you're used to working with a word
processor is that a rectangle has side
lengths of X Plus 1 and X plus 3 is not
on a new line it just continued at the
end of the first line and when we look
at the code that's not what we might
expect to happen because in in a word
processor when you hit return right here
then the output actually shows that you
hit return right there and that's not
going to happen here with our code our
code is only going to create a line
break if we tell it to create a line
break and there are two ways to create
line breaks and the same thing is true
in a word processor there's two ways to
create line breaks you can do a soft
return you can do a hard return
so a hard return is going to start a new
paragraph if I want a hard return what I
want to do is to just insert a blank
line in between hello this is my first
latex document and then the next
sentence so if I leave a blank line in
between those two sentences then the
compiler knows to insert a hard return
so let's compile recompile that
and now we can see that we did in fact
get a hard return
so a rectangle has side lengths blah
blah that is the second paragraph now
that's a hard return if you want a soft
return
so let me go back here if you want a
soft return then at the end of your line
where you want the line break you type
two backslashes okay so we will compile
that
and now we can see that we got a a new
line for a rectangle has side lengths of
however this looks a little bit
strange right it looks different than
what we saw before because a rectangle
is starting further off to the left than
hello this is a soft return so it didn't
create a new paragraph
and therefore the line is not indented
so by default I haven't typed much code
granted but by default here new
paragraphs are going to be indented so
the hello is indented a rectangle is not
indented because it was just a soft
return it's not a new paragraph
now
you can do something like this but it's
it's not
preferred what's going to happen if I do
this let me turn on my messages log
oh it actually didn't mind it okay I was
expecting it to not like the combination
of the soft and hard return there but it
seems to be okay
I like having this space in my code
because it makes it easier you know for
me to go back and find things
versus this where everything just kind
of runs together but you can decide
which one you like better softer turn or
a hard return there and you there are
also ways that you can turn off the
indenting because remember whether you
do a softer turn or hard return is going
to affect the way that your paragraphs
are indented or your lines are indented
so let's go ahead and do a hard return
right these do seem like they're
probably separate paragraphs
and we'll update that I'm just using F1
to recompile and there's still an issue
here something that's okay but it's not
great and that is that the x that I
typed doesn't look like math it just
looks like the letter X as if I had
typed a word with an X in it so when we
type variables in math typically we want
them to be italicized so they look like
variables and that's going to happen
automatically as long as we tell the
compiler that hey this is math it's not
text so we're going to use something
called Math mode to enter Math mode
you type a dollar sign to start Math
mode and then another dollar sign to end
Math mode
and you can see that the color changed
when I did that when I typed that first
dollar sign everything after the dollar
sign turned green so Math mode things
are going to be green and then when you
end Math mode everything that's outside
of math mode is going to go back to its
normal color so the word and is black
that's text mode okay so Math mode text
mode and I want this X plus 3 to be in
math mode as well so I'm going to type
dollar signs
around the X plus 3 and let's recompile
and we can see the difference visually
now that X is italicized the spacing is
a little nicer because it knows that
it's math and it needs to space things
in a certain way to make everything look
uniform
all right I'm going to add some more to
this I'm going to add another sentence
so we have a rectangle has side lengths
of X Plus 1 and X plus three
I'm going to say the equation
a of x equals
x squared plus 4X Plus 3.
gives the area of the rectangle so I
want you to just anticipate what's going
to happen when I compile what do you
think this is going to look like
so I'm going to hit F1 to compile
and I have encountered my first error
okay I can see that below here these
things are popping up in red something
has gone wrong something's wrong on line
six and line seven and it's kind of
giving me an indication it says missing
dollar sign inserted right it didn't
actually insert it for me but that is a
a clue for me of what went wrong oh I
probably forgot a dollar sign somewhere
so a of x equals x squared now the
letter A the letter X like those could
be text so that's not what caused the
issue I think it was this symbol right
here this carrot symbol
is only going to work in math mode it's
not going to work as text so I'm going
to
put my equation in math mode by typing
dollar signs around it and now we should
be okay
so again we see
that the paragraphs are indented now
that now that the paragraph is long
enough to wrap down to another line we
can see the way the indenting is working
here so things are not great right this
is okay it's in math mode the math
actually looks good except for the fact
that a of x equals is on one line and
then the rest of the equation is on
another line so that's not great if you
want to make sure that to
um
keep your equation on a line you can put
curly brackets around it and now when I
recompile it's going to protect that for
me so a of x equals x squared plus 4X
plus 3 all got pushed down to the next
line okay so looking pretty good still
like if I I mean I'm still not that
happy with it I think there should be
some space between the paragraphs right
but you know we're just talking about
the basics right now so the next thing I
want to tell you about is the difference
between there's kind of two different
math modes there's
displayed Math mode and then there's
inline Math mode
if you use displayed Math mode whatever
is in your displayed Math mode is going
to be on its own line so we often see
this in math textbooks
where equations are put on their own
line and to enter displayed Math mode
all you have to do is type two dollar
signs to begin displayed Math mode and
then two dollar signs to end displayed
math modes let's recompile
and now we see that the the math in
displayed Math mode got centered on its
own line and there's some nice spacing
there to separate it from the text and
then the text just continues after that
it's this is still happening like within
a paragraph
versus inline Math mode like the X Plus
1 and the X plus three those just appear
in line with the text
Okay so we've covered some basic
information let's go ahead and I'm going
to close this and then just show you now
what I have in my folder where I created
my tech file
okay so if we navigate back to the
folder where I created and saved my tech
file now I see there are actually two
files there there's the tech file that
ends with DOT Tex and then there's the
PDF file so the tech file
is our code and here we can just see
what that what just the text the code
itself looks like there's a little
preview of that and then here is the PDF
so that's not all fitting on the screen
let me make that a little smaller
and there we go okay so that is the PDF
document that I created
check the description below for links to
the files I created in this video as
well as links to the software that I
recommend using in the next tutorial
we'll look at how to typeset commonly
used mathematical notation using latex
hello I'm Michelle crummel and in this
video I'm going to show you how to type
commonly used mathematical notation in
latex
I'm working with the software
program called tech maker but you can
use any text editor that you like if you
watched my previous video creating a
latex document I showed you how you can
use overleaf so that you don't have to
download and install any software
overleaf runs right in your web browser
so there is a link in the description
below that you can click on if you want
to create an overleaf account and work
purely online if you want your screen to
match mine exactly you're going to want
to download tech maker make sure that
you do have mictec or Mac Tech installed
before you install techmaker so I am in
techmaker right now and I'm going to
create a new file so just click on that
icon here and it looks like I have you
know a new file ready to go it looks
like it might be called Untitled one but
actually we haven't saved this we
haven't really created it yet so before
we start typing any code this is very
important we need to save this file and
name it otherwise guys you could type
all kinds of code in here and when you
go to compile you're just going to get
an error and it's not going to be able
to do anything we have to save this file
and name it first before we're going to
be able to compile it so let's do that
file will save as
and you can save it anywhere you like on
your computer I'm just going to call
this one tutorial two
and I mentioned in my last video you
don't want
spaces in your file names your text
files should not have any spaces in the
file name so use an underscore or a
hyphen or simply just you know run all
of the words together and
that will automatically assign an
extension of dot t e x to that file so
here's my tutorial O2 Tech file and now
I can start typing my code
so we always start with backslash
document class and tech maker is making
this suggestion for me so I can hit
enter as a shortcut here and have it
fill in some of that for me now the
square brackets are where we would Place
optional arguments here it's unnecessary
if I didn't want that I could delete
that and just have the curly brackets we
do need the curly brackets here the
clasp that we are using today is article
so that's fine I can do that if I do
want to include some optional arguments
one of the more common ones would be to
declare the font size so your choices
are 10.11 point or 12 point I usually
like to go with 11 point
and then we're always going to have
backslash begin document
and backslash end document that pair of
commands there so I'm not going to
compile yet I don't actually have any
content we have to start typing
something first we're working on
mathematical notation today so I'm just
going to go through lots of different
categories and then show you how to type
various Expressions that you might need
so let's start with superscripts so I'm
just going to type the word superscripts
and now that I have something here when
I build we should be able to see that
and I'm just going to set this to oops
not that
um
let me just set the width here so that
we're seeing the whole page
that that looks about good right there
okay so superscripts and we want to
actually type something with the
superscript in it so that was just in
text mode and I'm going to type 2x to
the power 3. so 2x cubed
2x for the exponent we use that carrot
symbol from the keyboard so there's 2x
cubed however if I compile this right
now I'm going to get an error because
this carrot symbol needs to be in math
mode not in text mode so to put this in
math mode remember we wrap it in dollar
signs and now I can build
so I'm building by hitting this Arrow up
here which is quick building for me so
it's doing two things it's compiling the
code and producing the PDF that we see
over here on the right
but I usually prefer to use my keyboard
shortcut which is just F1 so if you
don't see me come up here and press this
button in the video then it's because I
just hit F1 on my keyboard if I hit F1
then it will compile
so I can tell that the 2x cubed is in
math mode because it turned green that's
one of the nice features about tech
maker that I like it does color code
different parts of the code so it's easy
to keep track of what you're doing
and if we look at a result
we've got I mean it's okay superscripts
2x cubed but I would like to separate
the 2x cubed from the text and put it on
its own line so we're going to do that
by using displayed Math mode I'm going
to use two dollar symbols at the
beginning and the end of that and it
puts the math mode on its own line
centered on the line like so
so next we're going to look at 2x to the
power 34.
again I'll use this displayed Math mode
2x to the power 34.
so think about what that's going to look
like the fact that I used double dollar
signs means it's going to be placed on a
separate line and it'll be centered on
that line so I don't have to worry about
putting in any kind of manual line break
like we practiced in the first tutorial
the double dollar signs will
automatically start a new line for me so
that's fine but if I want 2x to the
power 34 what I'm expecting to see is x
in the base and 34 in the exponent and
if we build this and let me zoom in a
little bit more so it's easier for you
to see
if we build this you can see that the 4
didn't go up into the exponent so by
default when you use this Keras symbol
only the single digit that comes next is
going to be placed in the exponent if
you want more than that in the exponent
then you have to use curly brackets
and you can use the curly brackets even
if you only have a single digit but I
normally don't bother if it's just a
single digit I don't bother putting the
curly brackets but now when we compile
we can see that the 34 has moved up into
the exponent which is what I had
intended
so another example let's do 2 times x to
the power 3x Plus 4.
2 times x to the power
3x plus 4. so if I want 3x plus 4 all to
be in the exponent then I need to put
curly brackets around that
and that looks like I expected it to
look
and then let's do 2x to the power 3x to
the fourth plus 5. so we're going to
have an exponent inside of an exponent
so 2x to the power curly brackets now
generally when I'm doing this I find it
quicker and easier if when I type the
first curly bracket I go ahead and type
the end one as well so that way I don't
forget it at the end especially if I'm
going to be using multiple curly
brackets just makes it less likely that
I'm going to forget to close one of my
opening brackets and then sometimes I'll
even just go ahead and go and do the
same thing with my dollar signs and then
I can just back up and enter what I need
to inside of the brackets so we're going
to put 3x to the fourth plus 5.
3x to the power 4
plus 5. so this exponent here
I didn't bother to use the curly
brackets I could have wrapped the four
and curly brackets but since it's just
one single
digit in the exponent it's unnecessary
okay so now we have 3x to the power 4
plus 5 all in the exponent here
and
now let's move on to subscripts
subscripts work in a similar way
so let's start with x sub 1 x sub 1 to
get the subscript you use the underscore
is that what it's called underscore and
then whatever you want in your Sub sub
script and again it will only put the
next single digit into the subscript
unless you use curly brackets so here
we've got x sub 1 and if I want x sub 12
for example x sub 12 this is not going
to work it's still going to just do x
sub 1 and then put a 2 right next to
that so that's not what we want here we
want 12 to be in the subscript so we put
curly brackets around
the 12.
and now we've got 12 in our subscript
you can have subscripts inside of
subscripts as well so let's just do x
sub 1 sub 2.
and I think this might cause an error if
we just type it like this yes it did
cause an error so we have to use curly
brackets here so the compiler knows what
it is we're trying to do because it's
different if you want x sub and then 1
sub 2 versus x sub 1
sub 2. so you have to decide how you're
going to put your curly brackets where
you're going to put your curly brackets
generally I would say x sub and then
everything you want in the subscript
should go in curly brackets like this
now look inside your curly brackets do
we need more brackets well since there's
just a single digit after the 2 right
here is just a single digit after this
subscript we should be okay with this
and let's see how that looks
so that's x sub 1 sub 2 and we could
even go further with that
if we wanted to do x sub 1 sub 2 Sub 3
like so but we're going to have to
figure out our brackets so x sub and
then use curly brackets around your
entire subscript
now within that Curly brackets we have
we need more brackets because we've got
two subscripts in there so we want to be
clear one sub and then we'll put curly
brackets around the two sub three
so I'm like nesting my subscripts here
let's see how that looks so one sub two
sub three and you could continue you
know to to do this as many times as you
need to
so let's do one more example let's say
we have a sequence and I'm not going to
to use the curly bracket notation and
let me just list some values so we might
have a sub 0 comma a sub 1 comma a sub 2
comma and then I want dot dot I'm not
going to type the dot dot dot there is a
latex command for that
backslash L dots is going to do three
dots the L is for lower they're going to
be aligned at the bottom like lower
aligned versus C Dots would be aligned
in the center
but l-dots will work for me fine right
here and then we'll say a sub 100. now
with 100 again I'm not going to type it
like this or it's only going to be a sub
1 and then two zeros next to it that's
not what we want we want 100 to be in
the subscript so we need curly brackets
there
there we go so a Sub 0 a sub 1 a sub 2
dot dot a sub 100.
next let's look at some Greek letters
we often use Greek letters in math
notation and one of the most popular
Greek letters that we use is the Greek
letter Pi
if you want to type Pi it's just
backslash pi
now that is the lowercase Pi if I wanted
the capital Greek letter Pi
backslash capital p i
like so
and that's the capital Pi if we want
other Greek letters we can just type the
name if you use a capital letter it's
going to give you a a capital Greek
letter if you use lowercase it's going
to give you the lower case Greek letter
for example we can do backslash Alpha
and that's going to give us the
lowercase Greek letter Alpha so you get
the idea there
and we might do something like a equals
pi r squared right area of a circle so
backslash Pi now it's important here
that I enter a space and then do my r
squared
otherwise if I don't have the space
there let me take out the space and show
you that because it's all running
together the compiler sees the command
as backslash PIR
th backslash PIR is not a valid latex
command so it's going to get confused
and we're going to get an error I'm
pretty sure we're going to get an error
let's try yep we're going to get an
error and you can kind of see it's
giving me a hint here of what what the
error is it's something like that PIR
see how to put a space between your
command and the next thing
and now it should be fine there we go
area equals pi r squared right here
okay so those are Greek letters there's
you can do many other Greek letters I'm
just showing you an example of a few
let's talk about some trig functions
if we want to enter for example y equals
sine of x y equals you're going to use a
first let me do it the wrong way
because beginners might be beginner
students often will just type this and
they might not even think there's
anything wrong with the way that looks
right I mean you can read it it says y
equals sign X but it is not displaying
the way we would like our mathematical
notation displayed the compiler because
you're in math mode here thinks that the
S is a variable the I is a variable the
N is a variable and the x is a variable
and so it's typesetting them all the
same way and you can see it looks very
uniform the way these letters have been
typeset they're all italicized and
spaced kind of the same way and they're
all running together that's not how we
want the sine of x to look so we put a
backslash in front of our trig function
sine cosine tangent secant cosecant
cotangent and now when I compile
you can see the difference the s-i-n is
not italicized and there's a little bit
of a space between the n and the X okay
so this is how it's supposed to look we
can do that for our other trig functions
like I said y equals cosine X
tangent X is t a n backslash t a n if we
want to do the reciprocal trig functions
y equals
unless you do cosecant is CSC secant
would be s e c cotangent would be c o t
and instead of X let's just do theta so
Theta is one of our Greek letters we're
going to do backslash and then type out
Theta I want a lowercase Theta here
we've got y equals cosecant Theta and
you can play around with it and see you
know what happens if you did a capital
Theta well we would get the Greek
Capital Theta but that's not what we
normally use for angles we use the
lowercase
there we go
so you don't want to forget when you're
doing your trig functions sine cosine
tangent secant cosecant cotangent to put
the backslash in front and the space
between the trig command and then the
argument or the angle
we can do inverse trig functions as well
so let's do sine inverse of negative one
y equals
sine inverse so backslash sine
and then for inverse
that we're going to use the notation
where it puts a negative 1 as a
subscript so remember how we did
subscripts it's the carrot I want
negative 1 in the subscript so I can't
just do this that's not going to work
that's only going to put the negative
symbol in the exponent the one will not
be in the exponent if I do that so I
have to use curly brackets negative 1
like so
and then of X or Theta or whatever we
happen to be using
oh I did say sine inverse of negative 1
didn't I although that's that's a little
confusing because we would have negative
one in two different places but if I
wanted the sine inverse of one half for
example we haven't done fractions yet
we're about to do fractions let's keep
it simple sine inverse of 1.
there we go could do that or Theta
or X or whatever we need there okay so
that's sine inverse now we could also
use the arc sine notation instead of
using that negative one superscript we
can just do
y equals arc sine and it again is
backslash and then you tarp type arc
sine Arc s i n
and then your angle
okay so by putting the backslash in
front of the arc sign it's indicating to
the compiler hey these are not variables
don't typeset them like variables so it
looks like it's supposed to look here
okay uh let's do log functions next
and we will start with just a common log
y equals log X now again
think about what's going to happen if I
compile this right now I'm in math mode
it sees the Y the L the O the G the X
thinks those are all variables so it's
going to look funny
I mean
you can understand what it's supposed to
be right but I do see beginning students
doing this a lot in their papers and
forgetting to put the backslash in front
of the log use the backslash and then
you need a space between the G and
whatever comes next
and then it will typeset this correctly
so only the variables X and Y are
italicized and the rest of the equation
is not
so there's the our common log y equals
log of x let's change the base in our
log so if we want
log backslash log oh that's supposed to
be equal y equals backslash log if we
want base 5 for example we need a
subscript so remember how we did
subscripts it's the underscore five
and then I'm going to type a space it's
not strictly necessary because if I
don't use curly brackets it will only
subscript this the next digit but just
to be clear I like to always put a space
there like that so this log
oh what did I do wrong oh I'm missing a
dollar sign double dollar signs
okay log base 5 of X and then let's do a
natural log
y equals backslash Ln
Space X
that's going to give us a natural log
next let's talk about square roots and
not necessarily square roots let's just
say roots in general because we can see
how to do cube roots or fifth roots or
seventh roots
so we'll just say roots in general
we'll start simple
square root of 2. so do a square root
we're going to hit backslash
s q r and tech maker is making two
suggestions for me here so we can see
it's backslash sqrt
and then we have an option where there's
square brackets curly brackets or we
have an option where it's just curly
brackets
if you're just doing the square root of
two you don't want the square brackets
you just want the curly brackets so sqrt
curly bracket two curly bracket like so
and that's going to give us the square
root of 2.
the other option is for when you want
roots that are not square roots so let's
do the cube root of two
you're still going to type backslash
sqrt so it's like you're starting the
square root command even if it's not a
square root but then you're choosing the
one that has the square brackets
followed by the curly bracket so I can
hit enter here to accept that and then
start typing or I could just keep typing
it manually so here the square brackets
are for the root if I want a cube root
then I type A 3. the curly brackets are
for what goes inside of that radical
symbol
so we want the cube root of 2 it's going
to look like so
cube root of 2.
now this one down here is my page number
it's bugging me a little bit so I'm
going to go ahead and turn off the page
numbers and to do that I'm going to
scroll back up
and I am going to after document class
I'm going to type
backslash page Style
curly brackets empty
I think that'll take care of that so let
me recompile
and then yep our page number is gone so
I'm turning that off just so that's not
in our way
okay back to more Roots let's do
something more a little slightly more
complicated like square root of x
squared plus y squared
so backslash square root
x squared plus y squared
okay looks good and now let's get
um
a little more complicated and put a
square root inside of a square root so
the square root of
1 plus square root of x
so we'll start with the outside root the
square root
okay the square root of now
once you start putting things inside of
other things it can get a little bit
confusing so what I will sometimes do is
just insert some Extra Spaces just so
it's easy for me to tell what's inside
of what because it's got a little
cushion around it so this is my like my
outside square root my big square root
and inside of the square root I'm going
to put 1 plus the square root of x so 1
plus backslash square root of x like so
and compile
and we've got one plus or the square
root of 1 plus square root of x
all right and then finally let's look at
fractions
so we'll do start with something really
simple we'll just do the fraction
two-thirds
so the command is backslash Frac for
fractions and you can see that tech
maker is is prompting me I can hit enter
to accept that
and this is in general what it looks
like when you want to make a fraction or
if I'm typing it manually
if I'm typing it manually I usually
still do kind of a template thing so
I'll do curly brackets for the numerator
and then curly brackets for the
denominator
and then I'll just use my cursor and go
back in
uh and that way I don't forget to close
my bracket so you have a pair of curly
brackets for the numerator and then the
next pair of curly brackets for the
denominator so in the numerator is 2 and
in the denominator we want three so this
should give me the fraction two-thirds
okay that looks good now I'm going to
next I'm going to type this in a
sentence
so let's just say about
and because I'm typing this in a
sentence I'm not going to use double
dollar signs I'm going to use single
dollar signs because I want this to be
inline Math mode
so my fraction two thirds
and I did that more quickly using my
keyboard because
let me do that one more time and explain
backslash okay so here I just hit enter
Because tech maker is going to populate
that for me and notice it automatically
highlighted the numerator so I type 2
and then I can hit tab on my keyboard
and then type the three so it goes
pretty quick once you get the hang of it
like that
rather than just typing it manually so
about two-thirds
of the glass
is full
and there's that sentence
so the two-thirds it's it's smaller
obviously in this sentence than the
two-thirds up here
when you're in inline Math mode
it's going to resize to to fit your
sentence right you don't want this huge
two-thirds but sometimes like if you're
writing a homework problem quiz it
worksheet something like that sometimes
your fraction is too small in the
sentence here and you do want to make it
larger so easy way to do that is instead
of backslash Frack use backslash defrac
The D is going to put it in displayed
Math mode
defrac so now when I compile it it's
going to be
oh it didn't like that
oh I may need a package in order to use
that
okay let me try this let me try this a
different way
because I haven't talked about packages
yet
but packages we will be using packages
soon another way to get into displayed
Math mode is to type backslash
display Style
let's try that
there we go so now it made the
two-thirds bigger same size as it made
it up here when you use double dollar
signs you're all you're automatically in
displayed Math mode and so everything is
large like this
if you just do the slash Frac in inline
math mode it's going to be small so this
looks kind of silly the two-thirds is is
really big compared to the rest of the
sentence I don't like that so I'm gonna
well I'll leave it in here just for
tutorial purposes let's maybe copy that
one more time
and take it out take out the display
Style
so you can see a comparison now because
I'm not
using double dollar signs it's not
automatically creating a new line so
here's where we have to decide how we're
going to break that line do we want to
do a double backslash like that
which will break the line
you can see I I'm sort of running into
an issue here because the lines are not
far enough apart I can manually add some
vertical spacing using square brackets
and then inside the square brackets tell
how much space I want so six and then
you can use any unit of measurement here
you can use centimeters six centimeters
would obviously be way too big I usually
use PT Point like Point size so give me
six points of space at the end of this
sentence and then when we compile you
see it just it inserted some vertical
space there for me
your other option if you don't want to
break the line that way would be to
leave an empty line in between
and that would also create a line break
we talked about this in the last
tutorial though notice it looks odd
because this new line right here is
starting a new paragraph and it's
indented versus this line up here did
not this this line up here is not
indented so that's why it looks a bit
funny there so I usually and it's just
it just depends on what you need but I
usually do something like this
when I want line breaks
and generally I if I want displayed
um
fractions display style fractions rather
than typing out display style I just do
backslash defrag
but I did get an error when I tried that
a moment ago
let's try it again
not that I'm expecting anything
different
two-thirds
and I just have to figure out which
package I need to use in order to get
that to work properly so I'm going to go
back up to the top and really quickly
just figure this out
use package
and let's go with
um
AMS math I'm gonna I'm gonna use a
couple packages here because I don't
want to do them one at a time and try
and figure this out AMS math AMS
Sim
and AMS fonts
okay one of those worked because now it
did compile correctly
and
oh that was
unnecessary because I had double dollar
signs so let me try that one more time
because the double dollar signs
automatically put it in displayed Math
mode so it's kind of redundant that I
used defrak inside of Double dollar
signs it's not necessary to do that
let's just try this again
and verify that we are getting a large
fraction here when we use defrac yep
and I needed a line break there
Okay so
uh you can accomplish the same thing
this way
and this way
let's try a more complicated fraction so
I'm going to do a line break here
again
um
now go ahead and put it in double dollar
signs so this isn't technically
necessary
let's do this uh let's do
a square root inside of our fraction so
let's do the square root of X Plus 1
over the square root of X Plus 2.
so we'll start with fraction
fraction like so in the numerator we
want the square root of x plus one so
backslash square root
like so X plus one that's my numerator
then here is my denominator so we're
going to do square root
X Plus 2.
and then close our dollar signs
and there we go so I did use you know
tech maker to my advantage there I
wasn't typing it all out manually if I
wanted let's try that one more time if I
were typing it out manually backslash
Frac
your curly bracket then slash square
root you have to open another curly
bracket so at this time you have to kind
of mentally keep track that you have two
curly brackets open and eventually you
need to close the two curly brackets so
X plus one close it for the square root
close it for the numerator then we open
curly brackets for the denominator
backslash square root
open curly bracket for the square root X
plus two close the square root close the
denominator
and then close Math mode
there we go
now sometimes we work with complex
fractions where you have a fraction
inside of a fraction so let's try that
so outside fraction
and Let's do
let's do one over
so just one in the numerator that's it
and then in the denominator let's do one
plus one over X so 1 plus now I need a
fraction so backslash frac
1 over X
like so
1 over 1 plus 1 over X
and you can of course have fractions
inside of fractions inside of fractions
you just want to pay attention to your
brackets make sure that they're paired
and like I showed you a moment ago
sometimes it is helpful to space things
out so my
um
denominator here
had a bunch of stuff in it you might
find it's helpful to kind of leave lots
of space in the curly brackets for the
denominator so that if you do get a
compiling error you can go back and see
that's probably where it would have
occurred because that you've got you
know complicated things inside of other
things
can be helpful as well
that wraps up this tutorial on common
math notation I do have another tutorial
on calculus notation which will be much
more involved there's lots of notation
that we use in calculus that we need to
use latex 4 because you can't type a lot
of the calculus notation using your
keyboard
but in the next tutorial before we do
that the next tutorial we're going to
look at brackets tables and arrays so
brackets include things like parentheses
and square brackets and curly brackets
and absolute value symbols we're going
to see how to make those things expand
in size because if you just type
parentheses let me show you real quick
right here around this
it's going to look really bad
well actually it doesn't look too
terrible but the 1 over X here is
longer vertically than the parentheses
so we're going to see how you can fix
that make your parentheses taller so
that they do wrap around the content
inside of the parentheses
and then we will look at tables we'll do
simple table we'll do a slightly more
complex table and then we'll look at
some arrays
hello I'm Michelle cremolin in this
video we are going to look at how to
type set brackets tables and arrays
using latex I'm working in tech maker
but you can work in any text editor that
you like or you can work online in
overleaf and there are links in the
description below to register for an
overleaf account if you want to just
work in your web browser so we have lots
of different type of bracketing symbols
when we use math notation but probably
the most popular would be parentheses
square brackets and curly brackets so
let's start there if you have a short
object then you don't need to do
anything special for parentheses let's
say for example
the distributive property
states that a times and notice I did use
a dollar symbol to enter Math mode a
times B plus c
equals a times B plus a times C for all
a b
c i can get fancy here with my notation
if I want I can use the element symbol
or the backslash in
and then if I want to say the set of
real numbers then there's a special way
to type that symbol as well backslash
math BB
curly brackets and then for the set of
all real numbers I need a capital R now
I think I'm going to have to load a
special package to make this work let's
see if I get a compiling error
I do okay so let's come back up here
in my Preamble everything before begin
document it's called The Preamble and
I'm going to use a package let's see AMS
fonts
AMS Sim
AMS math I always load those three
packages right off the bat so to be
honest with you I don't even remember
which one of the three I need it's only
one of those three that I need to make
this mathbv command work I'm just so in
the habit of using all three packages
all the time so don't remember which one
does what
that worked and we can see the result
here the distributive property States
and so here we have this in math mode a
times B plus C the parentheses look good
they are sized appropriately for what's
inside equals a B plus AC for all a b
and c in the set of real numbers
now square brackets work in a similar
way you can just type them using your
keyboard so let's use a line break here
there's a couple ways to do a line break
I like to do the double backslash and
then insert a little bit of extra space
there are lots of other ways to get
spacing between your lines things that
you can do in your Preamble so that you
don't have to do this every single time
you can change the line spacing
throughout your whole document but
that's a little more complicated and
we're trying to keep things really
simple for right now so I'm just going
to to do that and next we'll say the
equivalence
class
of a I'm putting a in math mode is and
then we'll use square brackets
around the a there and I will typeset
that
so I'm just using F1 on my keyboard
because that's a keyboard shortcut for
tech maker to compile otherwise I could
also come up here and click this Arrow
okay so the equivalence class of a is a
and you can see the square brackets
appear as expected a is just a normal
sized element so the brackets don't need
to be larger smaller they're sized
appropriately
okay this does look a little weird
though because the first sentence is
indented and the second one is not this
double backslash creates a soft return
it doesn't start a new paragraph and so
this
um sentence that I have here is not
considered a new paragraph and it is not
indented I'm not in the habit of
worrying about that because I almost
always turn off indenting in my
documents
so I'm going to come back up into the
Preamble it's the area before begin
document I'm going to type slash pair
indent
is going to change the the rules for
paragraph indenting I'm going to say 0px
so indent my paragraphs by zero pixels
in other words don't indent my
paragraphs and then I'll recompile
and you can see that none of my lines
are indented that's just my preference
the way that I like to work you
certainly don't have to do that now
let's take a look at curly brackets so
parentheses easy you just type them on
your keyboard square brackets easy just
type them on your keyboard curly
brackets not quite so easy
say the sets
a
is defined to be
and then we'll just call a the set of
the numbers one two three so curly
bracket one two one two three curly
bracket close Math mode and then compile
oh what did I do wrong here
forgot my square brackets in front let's
try that again okay now I didn't get the
result I expected because I typed curly
brackets around this set but the curly
brackets didn't show up on my PDF and
that's because the curly bracket is a
symbol that is reserved for part of the
coding in latex that is a special symbol
that tells the compiler something and so
you can't just type a curly bracket and
get it to show up you have to do
something different if you want the
curly bracket to show up you type a
backslash in front of it and that's true
for this
opening curly bracket and also the
closing curly bracket you put a
backslash in front of it and now when we
compile
the symbols will show in the PDF so the
compiler knows that this is not
um the coding curly bracket is actually
one that needs to be displayed
now another symbol that is reserved for
special syntax in latex is the dollar
symbol and we've seen that many times so
far the dollar sign is used to indicate
that we're starting Math mode but
sometimes you might want to display a
dollar sign right if we're talking about
money so for example
the movie tickets
costs
11 and 50 cents
okay so right away I know that I have a
problem here because this has turned
green
this has turned green so the compiler
thinks that I'm I've opened Math mode
and I have not closed Math mode well I
can close it here
and that's a little better we're back to
normal down here
but now clearly the dollar sign this
dollar sign is not going to be displayed
because this is just telling me that I'm
in math mode so let's compile that and I
don't see the dollar sign so if you want
to see a dollar sign well first of all
if we type in extra one
inside Math mode we're going to have
issues you that confuses the compiler so
if you want to display the dollar sign
you just type A backslash in front of it
same with the curly bracket and now when
we compile it knows oh this dollar sign
is meant to be displayed and so it will
print it on our PDF and we've got 11.50
now sometimes you want to put brackets
whether they're parentheses or square
brackets or curly brackets or absolute
value symbols or some other symbol's
greatest integer symbols that type of
thing sometimes you want to put those
around
notation that is much bigger taller so
let me show you what I mean by that
and here I'll just do I'm just going to
do a hard return here
and let's type this fraction
I'm going to do double dollar signs to
get give me displayed Math mode so it's
going to put this math on its own line
Center it on the page and I'm going to
type a fraction
so my fraction is going to be 1 over x
squared minus 1.
here's my fraction 1 over x squared
minus 1. let's say I want to put
parentheses around that
I don't know why maybe there's a
two in front of it yeah let's do that
okay that looks pretty bad the
parentheses are not tall enough they're
not surrounding the information inside
of the parentheses now if I wasn't in
displayed Math mode it would be a little
better so instead of double dollar signs
let me go back to single dollar signs
and show you it's a little bit better
it's still not perfect the parentheses
still don't seem to be tall enough to
cover what's inside of them so it's not
just because I'm in displayed Math mode
that that's an issue but it's more
pronounced when you're in displayed Math
mode
how can we fix that well we can make the
parentheses automatically
change in size to fit whatever's inside
of them
by typing go to your your parentheses
where they start so your left
parenthesis I think is the singular of
parentheses go to your left parenthesis
and type backslash left in front of it
and then go to the right parenthesis and
type backslash right in front of that
one and now let's compile that
and you can see that they've
automatically expanded
to an appropriate size that looks much
better
so this works with
lots of different bracketing symbols I'm
just going to copy this a couple of
times and we're going to change the
parentheses to square brackets square
bracket
square brackets
and curly bracket
now remember to get the curly bracket to
show up you have to put a backslash in
front of it
and compile
and there we go so we've automatically
expanded the size of our brackets in
these three examples
if you're working with vectors you might
even want an angular bracket
so
let me delete I'm just going to space
this out a bit
um
if we want parentheses we would type
parentheses like this
let's go back to parentheses
okay that's normal parentheses but if
you want an angular bracket instead of
parentheses you're going to type
backslash
L angle so left angle and then over here
instead of parentheses you're going to
type slash R angle
slash R angle for right angle and then
when we compile that you get your
angular brackets
you might also need to do this for an
absolute value expression so instead of
this left angular bracket we can just
use on the keyboard type the I think
it's called a pipe
but it's right above the return key or
the enter key
to get
your absolute value symbol
to expand
so backslash left backslash right is
going to expand the size of those
brackets
now there might be a case where you just
need
a bracket to show up on one side not the
other an example of this could be in
calculus
if we have something like d y d x
at x equals one we could use a notation
so let me start with a fraction for the
dydx to backslash frac d y d x
and now I want dydx
at x equals one or when x equals one so
normally the way we write that is we
would do a vertical bar
and then a subscript so here's a
subscript
of x equals one now if I just type x
equals one only the x is going to be in
the subscript so I need to put curly
brackets around my x equals 1 if I want
that all in the subscript let's see how
that looks
so I'm almost there but that vertical
bar that pipe symbol it's not tall
enough I want it to expand so let's try
that trick where we type A backslash
left or backslash right in front of it
let's do slash right
to get it to be larger now when I try
and compile this I'm going to get an
error because when you use a slash write
command you have to have a matching
slash left and vice versa so when you do
slash left you need a slash right but I
don't want a symbol to show up on the
left we can get around that though I'm
going to go ahead and type the slash
left
and then in order to tell it to not
display a symbol I'm just going to use a
period just type a period on your
keyboard and it won't display that so
now the notation looks proper
so hopefully that covers all of the the
types of bracketing symbols that you
need and you can certainly have bracket
like brackets around something that's
inside of something else so you could
have multiple pairs of brackets
all in sort of one expression
for example let's let's kind of build
off of
well let's do
a fraction we'll do a complex fraction
so fraction we'll do one over one plus X
to start with
and let's say we want
um
to put parentheses around that
so we'll do slash left and then the left
parenthesis
slash right and the right parenthesis
compile that so that looks good and I'm
going to put a One Plus in front of this
okay so there we are now now I want to
make this all the denominator of another
fraction so it'll be one over one plus
one over one plus X
okay so this whole thing that I've typed
right here I want to be in the
denominator
of a fraction so I'm going to put curly
brackets around it that's the curly
brackets for my denominator in front of
that I'll do another pair of curly
brackets for the numerator and the
numerator is just going to be one and in
front of that I need my fraction command
let's compile that
so there we go and notice that the
parentheses are adjusting in size to fit
like the container what's inside now
let's say I want to put big parentheses
around all of that so in front I'll do a
slash left oh I'm in the wrong place
sorry go to the very front
there we are slash left parentheses
and then go to the very end here slash
right parentheses
compile now you can see those
parentheses are really big so they are
automatically going to adjust to the
content inside of the parentheses
okay let's move on and talk about tables
I'll just give myself some space here
and
we will look at tables
we'll start with a very simple table and
then we'll add some more components to
it
so first of all to start my table it's
backslash begin curly brackets tabular
actually I'm gonna yeah hit enter and
let it kind of finish that out for me so
with the begin tabular you'll have an
end tabular and notice that we have an
extra pair of curly brackets after begin
tabular so here you have to
establish like how many columns you want
in your table
let's say we're going to make a table
with
X values of one two three four five so
we need six columns in our table six
columns in our table I can type c c c c
c I typed a c six times each one of
those C's represents a column so this is
going to be a table with six columns now
the reason I typed C was not C doesn't
stand for column C stands for centered
because your the text or the whatever it
is you're putting in the cell of your
table it can be Center aligned left
aligned or right aligned
so right like normally I would say
probably your mathematical tables your
values are going to be centered in the
table cell so I normally use seeds if I
wanted items in my cells to be left
aligned I could use else
that would give me a table with six
columns if I wanted the content to be
right aligned
I would use ours you can also do any
kind of combination
you identify for each column if you want
the content to be aligned left Center or
right
let's go back to Center aligned
and then we have to type some content
for our table so I'm going to type this
is what I want in my table x one two
three four five
so this is not going to work right now
if I compile
oh it actually did give me something but
it's not a table
this is just one this is all in one
column right now all in one column the
way that you
separate items
into columns is with the ampersand
so now if I compile X is in the First
Column and then right now one two three
four five is in the second column
so we want to go through here and put an
ampersand in between
like so
okay now we have a table with
six columns which is what I wanted I
guess it would be easier to see you just
kind of have to trust me right now how
many columns I have it would be easier
to see if we had you know lines
separating
so I should have done that let me go
back and show you how to do that if you
want vertical lines like in between your
table columns then you come back up here
and you use that pipe symbol on your
keyboard it's above the return key or
the enter key and
put that in between each one of these
like so let's recompile
and we get those vertical bars so now I
can see how many columns I had so let me
take out my ampersands let me go back to
what it was
one two three four like that and you can
see that it was all smushed into one
cell which is not what we wanted so you
need to use the ampersands
to separate
the the content into your different
columns now when you get to the end of
your first row you hit two backslashes
to indicate that that is the end of the
row
okay so here we are
then you can do your next line so the
next line let's say we want f of x
and and then whatever our f of x values
are we'll just do
[Music]
.
10 11
12.
13.
14 and we'll end that line
okay that's all right now the X and the
f of x they don't look like math they're
in text mode they're not in math mode so
let's fix that put dollar symbols
dollar signs around the X and around the
f of x
all right that looks much better now
we're missing the lines that separate
our rows right so in order to get a
horizontal line we're going to type
backslash H line
I will compile that and it gives me a
horizontal line so I did that at the end
of the first row and I'm going to do
that again at the end of the second row
now I need to do that
above my first row
okay and there is a basic table
sometimes I like to after the First
Column put a double pipe here
to separate the label x f of x from the
values in the table like so so we can do
that
so that is a very basic table right
there
let me copy that
and let's say that
instead of 10 for f of 1 we had a
fraction here so we'll do we'll do math
mode
slash Frac and we'll just use the
fraction one half
oh let's let's put let's separate these
tables a little better
so I'm going to insert some vertical
space here slash V Space
and then I can decide how much vertical
space I'm going to put one centimeter of
space right there to separate those
tables
and I'm going to turn off my page
numbering as well so I'm going to go all
the way back up to the top
slash page Style
empty
compile and that turned off my page
numbers okay so there are my tables let
me scroll back down here
so I'm working with that's the copy of
my first table right here we changed F
of one to equal one-half and you can see
that the one half because it is taller
than these other values is sort of
touching the the top and the bottom of
the row border we want to give this a
little more space and so let me show you
how you can add a little more to this
table instead of starting with begin
tabular we're actually going to start
with Slash begin
table now if I hit enter it's going to
put my end table right here I need the
end table to go after the end tabular
it's like a sandwich right we've got
begin table begin tabular and then at
the end we have end tabular end table
okay so I mean that hasn't changed
anything yet let me recompile we're
still in good shape
actually I lost my second table
I think that begin table
requires a package hang on let me do
full page I wasn't expecting that to
have oh okay
here's the second table up here yes so
this is the frustrating thing about
working with tables
in a word processor when you enter a
table you're very specific about where
you want that table to appear it's
wherever you type it wherever you enter
it that's where it's going to be
displayed right in a word processor not
so here
here when you enter a table
the compiler is going to decide where it
thinks that table will fit best on your
page
so you can see what happened to us here
and the second table is the one that had
the fraction one half for f of one so
that's this table at the top here it it
got moved up to the top of the page
that's not where I want it I want it
down here at the bottom of the page and
normally you're particular about where
you want your table to go if you're
creating a a long paper you might not
matter so much whether it's you know on
the page before or on the next page or
at the top of the page or at the bottom
of the page like you might be fine with
giving the compiler the flexibility to
decide where it thinks the table will
fit best
there is a way that you can tell it no
no no I want it to appear right here in
the code where I've entered it and all
we need to do for that is square
brackets and a capital H so let me
recompile
and I think I need the flow package for
this let me go back up to the top
backslash use package
float
yes I did
we'll talk about packages more in
another tutorial but for certain
commands in latex you need to load a
package before the command is going to
work
so in order to use this right here we
need to load the float package all right
so now we're good to go let me make this
larger again
there's our second table
and we were talking about the spacing
issue I want to add more space in there
so in between
begin table and begin tabular I'm going
to type backslash def that's going to
define something new
and then backslash array stretch
and then in curly brackets you're going
to type a number and the number that you
type is going to determine how much
extra spacing you have I usually go with
1.2
so let's compile that and see how that
looks so just added a little bit of
space right you can make that bigger
make like sometimes I'll go up to 1.8
go with 2 and see what happens
okay so if you go with two then you get
that's too much space like now it's
starting to look a little bit weird
maybe we'll we'll split the difference
we'll go like 1.5
all right that looks pretty good it's
not perfect like there's more space at
the top than the bottom so you can play
around with that if you don't like
exactly how it looks but that's an easy
way to get some extra padding if you
will in your table cells
the other thing we can do by starting
our table with begin table
in addition to the begin tabular is we
can now add a caption to our table and
you can add the caption above your table
or you can add the caption below your
table let's add it below
and so after the in between the end
tabular and the end table I'm going to
type slash caption
and then
you can enter your caption
so
I don't know what we want to say these
values represent
the function f of x
and we'll compile that
and yeah that looks a little weird
because let me go back full page
the caption looks like it's being
centered
whereas the table is not being centered
so that is a bit strange if I want my
table centered
then again in between begin table and
Define and begin tabular I can do
backslash centering
and that will Center the table I
normally Center my tables so I wasn't
expecting that issue I'm not used to
that popping up especially when I'm
captioning things I'm just I like
normally in my workflow I Center my
tables
so I'm sure there is a way to get the
caption to go to the left you can force
things to be flushed left if they're not
automatically that way
um but
it's easy it's an easy fix if you just
want everything settled centered and
there we go
now there are a lot of other things you
can do to create more complex tables
um I don't want to spend too much time
but there are some instances where you
might want
um what's it called
where you have like uh
something that spans over two table
columns I know there's a word for that I
can't think of it off top of my head but
you can do something oh oh merging cells
I think is what it's called in like
in the spreadsheet program where you can
merge cells together so you can do
things like that as well with tables
you can also
sometimes you might want to have
a sentence in a table cell that sounds
that sounds kind of weird but I I could
think of of an instance let's just do
one real quick I'm going to copy this
table
so here's a copy of that table
which didn't fit on page one so it got
pushed down to page two we'll make this
a little bit bigger
and
um let's do something where we have just
like
two columns in our table
and I'm gonna put text in here
so we might want to set centered we
might want it flush left we'll see how
it goes I'm doing this off the top of my
head
and we'll only have two columns so it
needs to look something more like
this
okay and we're going to say at the top f
of x
and then in the second column at the top
we'll do F Prime of x
and
here we'll say x greater than zero
and here we'll say
function
f of x
is increasing so let's see what that
looks like
so this is a different kind of table is
just doesn't have just numeric values in
it
it looks a little bit odd let's change
the caption too so this makes a little
more sense
we'll say
the relationship
between f
and F Prime
okay and we could if we want to this
time move the caption to the top
and notice that that automatically
numbered the tables I didn't point that
that out either
it didn't happen with this table because
with this really simple table we just
used begin tabular end tabular
with these next two tables we started
with begin table before we did the begin
tabular and that gave us all these extra
options and one of them is that it will
number your tables as you go so I didn't
type table one
that was this table right here I did not
type table one anywhere it just knows
that that is the first table
in this begin table sequence and then
this next one when I began a new table
now it knows oh that's table number two
so it is numbering that for me which is
nice
okay
um what I wanted to show you though was
how you can deal with long sentences in
your table
so I'm going to copy this sentence a
couple of times
which isn't very realistic but let's
just say like you had a lot of text to
put in your table salt okay then this
happens let me make this okay this looks
horrible right the table got cut off
because the the content inside of this
one cell is so long it doesn't fit and
so it ran off the page which is
definitely not good we don't want that
so an option if you're trying to type
text like long text in a table instead
of using a c here
and let's go ahead and change these to
L's anyway first just to show you
that when I do that
now in my table
this became left Justified instead of
centered all of this became left just
Justified but what I can do with this
instead
this second column because I know that
it has to accommodate such long text is
to put a p and the P stands for
paragraph So it's indicating that
there's we want this cell to contain a
paragraph and then in curly brackets you
indicate how wide you want that
paragraph to be so maybe we want it to
be two centimeters you can use inches
you can use other measurements that you
want okay so now at least it fits on the
page it still looks a little funky right
but you can change this we could even go
with two inches
three inches you can adjust it to fit
your needs and you can do that for each
column so if you have multiple columns
with a lot of text in it you can do that
all right that's the basics of working
with tables
there are a lot of other ways to
customize tables you can do shading you
can do all sorts of things but this will
get you through most of what you need to
do with tables
we're going to wrap up this video today
by talking about equation arrays
and so
the easiest way I have found
to create arrays is with the Align
command now there is also an equation
array command and by that I mean you can
do backslash begin EQ n you can see
right here begin equation array you can
do it this way and I used to do it this
way but now I have a different way that
I prefer to do it so I'm going to do
slap let me first of all just say put a
little header here arrays
and we're going to do backslash begin
a line
now we have two options here we've got a
regular a line and then we have an align
with an asterisks asterisk after it
let's go with the regular one first and
then I'll explain what the S drisk does
okay so begin a line
and we have to put some kind of content
in here so let's use this to solve an
equation 5X
squared now notice when I type started
typing this is in green and green
indicates that we're in math mode but I
didn't type a dollar sign when you're
inside of the Align environment you are
automatically in math mode
so if I start typing text now see the
text is still green that text is
actually in math mode let me compile and
show you right this this looks really
wonky
everything in a line is in math mode so
if you actually want text you have to
have some way to tell it wait wait I
don't want this to be Math mode and you
can do that with backslash text
and then just type your text let me
change the text
um place your words here
oops curly bracket let's compile that so
now it knows that that's text and we
still have a lot like a spacing issue
here in math mode
this hasn't come up yet but in math mode
the compiler ignores spaces like after
the between the five and the X here I
can type as many spaces as I want
they're not going to appear on the
document when I compile it the 5 and the
x squared are still right next to each
other so in math mode spaces get ignored
and that's why
this space is being ignored so the p in
this word is right next to the two if
you need a space there's a couple things
we can do in the text mode we can just
type a space and that'll take care of
that so that worked or in math mode if
you need to force a space that will be
displayed you do backslash comma so
either one of those methods will work
okay but that's not actually what we're
trying to do here so let me take that
out
5x squared we're going to solve an
equation 5x squared minus 9
equals X Plus 3.
so what I want to do next is subtract
the X on both sides subtract the 3 on
both sides and then write the result
okay so I need to end this line with a
double backslash and on the next line
type what I want next 5x squared
minus X
minus 12.
oh equals zero right equals zero
okay so that's all right notice that
I've got my equations on their own lines
and the equations are being numbered so
I didn't have to tell it this is line
number one this is line number two it's
going to number them and if I create
another
a line just duplicate this one and
compile it
it continues numbering from where it
left off before which is really nice in
a math paper because your equations are
all numbered and then when you're
talking about them in your paragraphs
you can refer to them by number you can
say in equation four blah blah blah
so that is that is nice there
what I don't like about what I'm seeing
though is that the equations are not
aligned at the equal sign it's much
easier for the reader to follow the
mathematics when you're solving an
equation or simplifying things you're
going step by step if you line up your
equal signs that's the proper way to do
it so in order to line up the equal
signs you just have to put an ampersand
in front of them
now if you only do it on the one and not
the other it doesn't know what it's
supposed to be lining up so that's not
going to work it's going to be funky
but if you put the Align in front of
both equal signs it knows to line up
those equal signs and this looks proper
this is what I wanted to see here
and we can of course add more lines than
this just do double backslash and keep
going
if you get to the point where there's
nothing on the left side of the equal
sign that's okay too
we can just say
Ampersand equals and it's going to start
with an equal sign and line it up
um so I don't know we could do 12 plus x
minus 5x squared
like so
and everything is lined up at the equal
sign there
now if you don't want the line numbers
to appear not just appear but if you
don't want your lines numbered that's
when you would use the asterisk if you
do it in the begin you have to also do
it in the end if they don't match you'll
get a compiling error so this is going
to turn off the equation numbering so
when I compile
the 3 4 and the five have disappeared
and then if I copy this one again
and compile
you'll see that it picks up where the
first numbered one left off so it's not
that it's just hiding the line numbers
it's not even numbering them so think
about that carefully when you use it
which way you prefer to go
okay that does it for this tutorial we
looked at lots of ways to use brackets
and to customize the height of the
brackets
we looked at tables and we looked at
arrays
hello I'm Michelle Cromwell and in this
video I'm going to show you how you can
create lists in latex so we'll be
looking at enumerated lists which are
numbered lists and then also itemized
lists which are bulleted lists and let's
begin by just listing some basic school
supplies so pencil
calculator
ruler
notebook
if I compile now take a minute to think
about what this is going to look like so
pencil calculator ruler notebook in a
word processor we would see these four
words each on their own line but in
latex
we can see that that does not happen I
don't have any line breaks coded here so
the words are just kind of flowing all
together on one line I could insert line
breaks but that's not what I want to do
I'm intending to make a numbered list
here
and so let's start over to create a
numbered list we call this an enumerator
list we start with backslash begin
enumerate
and when you have a begin enumerate you
also have to have a matching and
enumerate okay so this begins this
environment enumerate environment but
now I have to actually uh list out all
of my items so then we're going to type
backslash item
and enter our first item which was
pencil hit enter and I don't need to do
anything to indicate a line break when I
type backslash item again the compiler
knows that this is a new item and it
belongs on a new line so slash item
calculator
slash item ruler slash item notebook so
let's try compiling this again and now
we have our enumerated list so as simple
as that
if we want a bulleted list then we
change from enumerate
to itemize so an itemized list
is a bulleted list and then when we
compile that we see that we have bullets
instead of numbers but I'm going to go
back just undo that go back to my
enumerated list because I want to show
you how we can then have an like a
nested list so another enumerated list
inside of this one so let's say under
notebook we have several items that we
want to keep in our notebook so I'm
going to hit return and I'm going to
indent you can indent just once or twice
however you like it and this is just
kind of to help organize the code and
make it easier to find things later if
we need to
so I'm going to do a new enumerated list
so I started with backslash begin
enumerate
and I need to end this enumerate and you
can see how it's indented and then
backslash item to list my first item so
in my notebook I have notes
and then we'll do backslash item
homework
we'll say these are the sections in my
notebook slash item assessments
and let's compile that and see what that
looks like so we have these sub items
and the compiler automatically indented
for us and instead of numbering it one
two three four now these are numbered a
b and c and you've got the parentheses
around the number so all of the the
numbering is happening automatically you
don't have to enter any of that manually
let's do this one more time let's see
how we can have like another level
and under assessments we'll say that we
have different kinds of assessments so
I'm going to hit enter I'm going to
indent again and I'm going to start over
with another begin enumerate
slash item to list my first item so
tests
quizzes
journal entries
and we'll compile that
and you'll see how that is now numbered
differently as well instead of ABC now
it's one two three
and if I want to add a fifth item I just
have to figure out where that belongs so
this was item number one
two
three
four and the indenting really helps to
stay organized because now I if I want a
fifth item I can kind of see where
that's going to go that's going to go
right here
slash item and what's another Supply
that we might need
we'll say highlighters
and that is now number five
now there are some things you can do to
change
the way the numbering appears if maybe
you don't want
one two three four maybe you want
capital a capital b capital c capital D
or maybe you don't want the parentheses
here
so let's look at a few other options I'm
just going to copy
my first list
and let's put some space in between
there
with V Space we'll do one centimeter of
space to separate that and now instead
of the default one two three four let's
say I want capital letters here in
square brackets I'm going to type it
the way that I want it to appear so I
want it like that capital A and then a
period
and let's compile
okay so we ran into a compiling error in
order to make this work we're going to
need to load a package
so I'm going to go into my Preamble
that's before the begin document
and use package
enumerate
okay use package enumerate let's come
back down here and try this again
and now you can see that that changed
that for me instead of one two three
four I've got the ABCD
now let's try this again I'm going to
copy
this here so just made a copy and maybe
I don't want it to be like that maybe I
want to start out like that
and we can do that maybe I want a
numbered list but I don't want it to
start with number one so here's just
kind of the default really basic list
right here but maybe I don't want it to
start with number one for whatever
reason maybe I'm creating a worksheet
and I you know on the last page I left
off with number five and now I want this
list to begin with number six
I'm going to type backslash set counter
enumi
and then six
and you can see that now it started with
number seven so that wasn't actually
what I wanted I forgot that I need to
say five if I want my list to start at
6 then I need to set the counters
position at five so that the next time
it sees an item it will think the last
item was number five and it'll make the
next item it sees number six so let's
compile this there we go that gave me
I'm starting a list starting with number
six
now let's create this list again I'm
going to go back up
and get this first list that I made with
all the different levels
we'll add some vertical space here
to separate things out visually
okay so this list started over with
number one and just make this easier for
you guys to see I'm going to insert a
page break here
instead of this vertical space we'll do
backslash page break
and that way this new list is on a new
page
and instead of an enumerated list I'm
going to change it into an itemized list
again
itemize and then I'm just going to copy
this
and replace all of these enumerates with
itemize
so I have a begin and an end three times
because I have three different levels of
my list here
and we'll compile that and I just wanted
to show you how this works in a bulleted
list so for the first level you've got
the the solid round black bullets
and then for the second level you've got
these dashes and then the third level
you have the asterisks
now sometimes you want to create a list
but maybe you don't want the numbers to
show
so let's just copy one of these basic
ones we'll take this one
I'm just going to copy that
let's add some vertical space here
okay and let me take out the
customization
and we have just a really basic
enumerated list one two three four let's
say for whatever reason we just don't
want these numbers to show while you can
simply type square brackets and leave
them empty don't type anything in the
bracket
and then compile
and there's a space there where the
number should be but it's hidden it's
not displayed okay so that's one way
around it you can still have something
formatted like a list with all of your
items and then you're not showing any
values you can also customize really
however you want this numbering to look
you can do it manually now it's not
ideal to number things manually it's the
wonderful thing about latex
is that everything does get numbered
automatically so if you come back later
and in between calculator and ruler you
want to add pen it's going to
automatically renumber things for you
whereas if you had manually said one two
three four now you would have to
renumber everything manually after that
so here
if you're okay with taking that risk you
know that you're not gonna you know it's
not that big of a deal to you you can do
some customization here let's say for
example you wanted this to be an A but
you didn't like you didn't like the
parentheses before and after you could
just do something like that
it's compile
and we see that it it looks like that
you can
um I don't know what else you might do
here you can even type words there if
you wanted to you could do one I don't
know why you would do that
but just to point out that you can
really customize this
and so these are right Justified so that
is one thing to be aware of it looks a
little weird
because it's ragged on the left
but if you do these customized labels
they're going to be right Justified here
and then your items themselves will be
left left Justified over here
hello I'm Michelle krummel and in this
video I'm going to show you some
different ways you can format your text
and your document so for example we'll
be looking at how to make things
italicized or bold how to change the
font size how to create sections and
subsections and organize everything with
a table of contents so let's start with
just some basic text formatting you can
change the appearance and the size of
your text to some extent so I'm going to
begin by typing a simple sentence and
we'll say this will produce
italicized
text so it won't of course because I
haven't done anything to indicate that I
need the text to be italicized this
right now is just producing normal text
but if I want the text to be italicized
let's just italicize the word italicized
then I'm going to in front of the word
type backslash text i t
curly bracket then I begin typing
whatever I want in italics and when I
get to the end of the text that I want
to italicized I close the curly brackets
so let's compile this now
and we can see that the word italicized
has been italicized so it's that
backslash text i t that's going to
italicize your text
let's try making something bold so this
will produce
bold text now in order to make your text
bold you use backslash text
the F for bold face font
so we'll say bold face is it face or
faced I don't know but it will be bold
and let's do small caps this will
produce so for small caps it's backslash
text S C
curly bracket
so we'll say small caps
and your curly brackets
and we'll compile that and we'll see
that we have small caps
and we can also do this will produce
type writer font so backslash text TT
nope
TT
so there's three T's there it's text TT
uh
hype writer font
text
so that typewriter font you might be
wondering why anyone would want to use
that but it is
um like mono spaced so it's good in
certain situations it's also I think
good for urls
to make them look a little bit different
than the rest of the text you can offset
something like saying please visit
Michelle crumbles website at and then I
can do my backslash text TT curly
bracket Opening Our bracket
and then it's http
slash slash
Michelle crumble.com
and you can see that it just sets the
text apart now if I were actually doing
a hyperlink this isn't the way I would
do it because we can load a package that
will make this link clickable
which would be even nice you can use the
hyperref package for that
I guess since I brought it up I'll go
ahead and show you
so we go into our Preamble which is
before the begin document after the
document class and we're going to do use
package
hyperref
okay that and then instead of this
backslash text TT I can just do
um URL
and let's compile that
and now I have a clickable URL and you
can see that it automatically put that
in the typewriter font I didn't have to
tell it to do that the that's just part
of the hyperf package it's doing that
and so now if I click on that in my PDF
is going to take you to my website you
can also customize this even more
because sometimes websites are really
long and ugly so you can do backslash
href
and then
the URL but then you need another set of
curly brackets and that's the text that
you want displayed
so maybe I'll just say my website
and we'll compile that
and now when you click on the words my
website oh it didn't work
oh it did work it just didn't give me
the little
um the little gloved hand icon
okay
so it did work when I clicked on it so
those are the some of the things you can
do to change the way that you're
displaying your text we can also change
our text size
so let's play with the sentence
please excuse my dear Aunt Sally which
most math students are familiar with
right order of operations parentheses
exponents
what is the m multiplication yes
parentheses exponents multiplication
division
wait what's the a
addition subtraction there we go it's
been a while sorry parentheses exponents
multiplication division addition and
subtraction okay
please excuse my dear Aunt Sally so
let's compile this just so we can see
what we're comparing this to and let me
give myself some vertical separation
here slash V Space
I'll just do one centimeter of vertical
space there
separate it from the work that we did
before
and we are going to make dear Aunt Sally
change size okay so let me copy this I'm
going to paste it several times
and this first time I'm going to make
dear Aunt Sally
large
really large
so to do that I there's a couple of ways
I can do that
let's start this way
backslash begin
large with a capital l
and then the text that you want large
I don't know should we include the
period or not include the period
I I guess we will not and then backslash
end
large with a capital l they have to
match remember whenever we do a begin
you're going to have to matching end so
let's compile that and see what we've
got
so my or just the dear Aunt Sally part
of that sentence let me zoom in here so
you can see this better
did get larger
I can I you know what I sh I should have
started even larger because we can go
larger
I'm gonna copy this
and try this with a lowercase L instead
which should not be quite as large as
the large with the capital L so now
we're going to have normal a little bit
larger and then a lot larger
here we go
and we can make this even larger if we
change large to huge
okay and we can make that
even larger if we change the lowercase H
to a capital h
and you can see that that got even
larger now we can go in the other
direction and make things smaller let's
go back to to just normal
and
we'll go a little bit smaller than
normal so normal you could also call it
normal size
so sometimes you need that if you have
like your whole document as large but
then you want one part of it to go back
to regular regular size let's do that
I'll show you that so you would just do
normal size all smushed together as one
word
okay so that's the same as this this
line oops
this line right here the first one okay
so let's go a little bit smaller than
normal size
and that's going to be script size
and we can go even smaller than that
and go I think I missed small I did we
missed small so let's put small in here
script size is smaller than small and
I'm
trying to do this in a logical way
so normal size and then if you want it a
little bit smaller you can go too small
and then if you want a little bit
smaller than that you can go to script
size if you need it even smaller than
that
we'll go to Tiny
okay
and let's compile that and see what
we've got there we go so progressively
larger and then progressively smaller
all the way down to Tiny
now we can also change how our text is
Justified so sometimes you want your
text to be centered sometimes you want
it left Justified sometimes you want it
right Justified
so add in some vertical space for this
new section here
and let's do centered text so for
centered text begin
Center
and we're of course going to need an end
Center as well
then everything you put in between begin
Center and and Center will be centered
so this line is
centered
and I could do all of that on one line
let's save some space
so we can do something similar I'm going
to copy that two more times instead of
Center we can do flush left
so we need to begin and end
or we can do flush rights
okay so then we can see our text and
zoom out a little bit
this line is centered this line is Oh I
should change that
is
left
Justified
this one is right
it's Justified
that makes more sense
all right so the begin and the end
is a nice way to do this with either
changing the font size or changing the
way that it is Justified
because it's just easy to see where that
starts and where it stops it's very
definitive like where that ends it's not
the only way you can do it
let me
copy these sentences here
and show you a different way and this
would work not just with the
justification but also with sizing as
well
if you do backslash centering
now notice I don't have a begin and an
end
if I do backslash centering it's going
to affect everything that comes
afterwards so all of those lines are
going to be centered
if I were to do backslash large
say for example then everything that
comes after that is going to be large
I don't know what's going on with the uh
that's weird why is it
oh I see this is indented all right I
thought maybe it was like weirdly
centered in one part of the page nope
this is just end indented that's all
that's going on because I did soft
returns here
there we go
they're all indented now okay so uh if
we change this to Tiny then everything
after that becomes tiny so it just
depends what you want to do if you want
to change your whole document then you
can do this something like this is very
simple I usually like the begin and the
end again because then when I'm going
back and looking at my code it's very
easy to see where that started and where
it ended
so that's what I've got for text
formatting now let's talk a little more
about document formatting
if you want to create
a little title section at the top of
your document
then you're going to come into your
Preamble so before the begin document
you're going to come up here and you're
going to enter three different lines
backslash title
with curly brackets
backslash author with curly brackets
backslash date
with curly brackets
now you don't have to type anything in
the curly brackets but obviously if you
want your title to show then you would
type something let me do a full page
view here so we can see what's going on
so let's just say for my title I'm going
to write my latex
documents and for author I'm going to
put my name
Michelle crummell and for the date I
have a couple of options I can manually
type the date what is today's date hang
on let me check
Sunday July 26th
so I could say July 26th
2020 like so now I'm going to compile
and notice nothing changed on the PDF my
title is not showing up so I've entered
the needed information to create the
title but I haven't actually told the
compiler to print the title in my PDF to
make it we have to actually tell it to
make the title so after begin document
you're going to type backslash make
title all one word and we'll compile and
now I have a title
so there's a couple of things I want to
point out with the date if you want to
manually enter the date you can
change that to anything I want any text
I want even if it's not a date if you
just want to put some other kind of text
there you can and you can still use the
backslash date coming and to do that
oftentimes what I will do for the date
is backslash today
and then when each time I compile
it'll figure out what is today's date
and then it'll display that date
so if I come back make some edits
compile this again later it'll always
have the most current date on it
my students don't always like to do that
because sometimes they turn in things
late and they don't want me to know that
they compiled it late
the other thing I want to fix here is
the word latex my latex document so the
word latex is normally typeset in a very
special way and to accomplish that you
have to do backslash and then you type
l-a-t-e-x and it needs to be done like
so with a capital l a lowercase a a
capital T lowercase e capital x and then
when we compile you'll see that it did
change like the font and spacing and
formatting of that latex let me zoom in
because it doesn't look quite right
because there's no space between the
letter Chi and the letter d
so I can create that space by typing
another backslash at the end of that
word and compiling it again and now we
get the space between the chi and the D
that is a basic little title section
on your first page
there's lots of other ways to create
title pages that then wouldn't have
other things on them
but we'll get into that in another
tutorial how to format a math paper
what we want to do here next is to
create some sections and subsections in
our document
so let me go to the end here
but before my end document
and create a section so my first section
I'm going to hit backslash section and
then in curly brackets type the name of
your section or the title for your
section so this will be linear
functions that's my first section I'll
compile that and you can see that
there's some automatic formatting that
happened to that that's not like normal
text linear functions for my section
here
it's bold It's a larger font size and
it's numbered and I didn't manually
number it the compiler will number it
and so if I create another section
create another section and call it
quadratic functions
pile and now that's section number two
we can create subsections
so underneath section one
I'm going to indent again just for my
own organization it's not absolutely
necessary I'm going to type backslash
subsection
curly bracket
we'll say slope
intercept form
and then let's do another one backslash
subsection
standard form
and one more slash subsection
point-slope form
let's compile that
so now we have subsections and the
subsections again are formatted in a
special way and they're numbered 1.1 1.2
1.3
if you don't like the way that the
numbering scheme looks you can change
that
you can also add sub subsections so
under our first subsection let's indent
and do backslash Sub sub section
example one
and one more
Sub sub section
example two
and compile
and now we see those subsections are
labeled 1.1.1 1.1.2
okay let's add a couple subsections
under quadratic functions and the reason
I'm doing this is because we are going
to build a table of contents so I want
to have enough to fill out my table of
contents so subsection here we'll do
vertex form
standard form
and factored form
and compile
okay there we go now if you don't want
the numbering to be displayed
then you type in asterisk after the word
section
so if I don't want those section titles
to have numbers in front of them I can
suppress that
same with the subsections
and do asterisks
and hide those so just hide a couple of
those okay so you can decide if you want
them numbered or not I'm going to undo
that because I do want them numbered for
my table of contents
okay so here we are I'm going to go back
up to the top of the document
and let's say the very first thing we
want after being in document is our
table of contents so backslash table of
contents all one word compile
and let me go full page now the contents
is blank
that's going to happen because it
requires two compilings in order to
create the table of contents so don't
panic if you don't see your table of
contents once you compile just compile
again so let's compile one more time and
there it is our table of contents
formatted very nicely with our page
numbers
hello I'm Michelle krummel and in this
video we are going to look at packages
macros and graphics
let's start by saving our file so I have
a file that I've already started and I
am just going to save that as
tutorial 6. so let me find the folder
where I want to save that
tutorial 6.
and if we look at that folder here we
can see that it is tutorial
06.tech and we're going to start by
looking at some packages that we can use
to change how this document looks
packages are used to load special
instructions for the compiler so you can
do things like add features that aren't
included in the standard distribution or
modify the standard rules for fonts and
document formatting if you want to use a
package you place it in the Preamble so
the Preamble is the section of code
between document class and begin
document so I'm going to come up here to
line number two and just hit enter a few
times to give myself some space and we
can start entering the packages that we
want to use so the first package I'm
going to show you is one that I use in
almost every document I create and that
is going to affect the size of the
margin
for my output document if you'll notice
and I'm going to change the zoom here so
that we can see the entire page there's
a lot of white space at the top and on
the left and on the right and even at
the bottom below the page number so this
is just the default margins that are set
here and normally these margins are too
large for the kinds of documents that
I'm creating I prefer to have about a
one inch margin so we can use a package
to deal with that now the easiest way if
I just want one inch margins on all
sides is to use a package called full
page to use a package we're going to
type backslash use package I'm going to
choose the option with the curly
brackets and then I'm going to type the
name of the package inside of the curly
brackets so it's just full page
and then I'm going to compile so we can
come up here to compile or I can just
hit F2 as a keyboard shortcut so notice
what happened now we've got a one inch
margin at the top at the left at the
bottom and let's go back to full page
view
and you can see we also now have
decreased that margin at the bottom so
that's just really quick easy package to
use if you want one inch margins on all
sides
now you can use different size papers in
the United States typically we use paper
that is eight and a half inches by 11
and if you want to make sure you are set
up for that you can come up here and
type letter paper to make sure we're
using letter paper if you are using a
four size paper you can type A4 paper up
here and when I compile I don't know if
you noticed that it went pretty quick
there was only a very slight difference
but look at the bottom of the page here
that did make quite quite a difference
so let me go back to letter paper
and that's going to give me that eight
and a half by 11 size paper now I might
not want one inch margins on all sides
we can customize this further if we use
a different package so instead of the
full page package I'm going to use the
geometry package and this is the one
that I use when I create all of my
documents just because it does give me
some more control so the geometry
package I think if I compile right now
it's not going to do anything I haven't
really told it what I want it to do yeah
it looks like it maybe it just went back
to the default
let's zoom in here a little bit now I'm
just a fit to page width here
and we can come in front of those curly
brackets and put square brackets and
that is where I'm going to enter the
options that I want to use with this
package so if I do want one inch margins
I'm going to type margin equals one inch
and compile
um F1 to compile I may have said F2
earlier I don't remember F1 to compile
and now I have one inch margin so this
really has the same effect as that full
page package when I when I do it like
this and just say give me one one inch
margins all all the way around
uh although it looks like we don't have
a whole lot of space under the page
number there
I can make this really specific and say
no I want the top
to be one inch and the bottom to be one
inch but the left
to be 0.5 inches and the right to equal
0.5 inches and let's compile that and
now you can see that I do have those
larger margins on the top and bottom
compared to what I have on the left and
right okay
um now my margins are a little bit too
small for my taste so I might change
that and you certainly don't have to use
inches you can use centimeters you can
use any valid measurement that latex
will accept here
okay typically I just use one inch but
we will leave that like so for now and
let's talk about
another package
actually before we move away from the
geometry package you can also explicitly
specify your paper size so let me just
show you that real quick we could say
paper width
equals 8.5 inches if we're working with
eight and a half by eleven and then we
can say paper height
equals 11 inches
okay so if I did want to change the size
of my output for my paper I don't know
maybe I want to do something crazy like
uh five by seven
and then we can see what happens so when
you print this it's going to print 5x7
instead of now eight and a half by
eleven so there might be some
applications for that if you're if you
want if maybe if you're making flash
cards for example and you want them to
be smaller
then you could adjust that paper size
even if your actual paper is not that
size it would restrict the output to
that size for you
okay so let's just go back
this is bugging me just because it's not
what I like to use okay there we go
that's making me feel more comfortable
I've got one inch margins all around
okay let's talk about another package
and sometimes you're trying to type
mathematical notation maybe you're
looking up some syntax to do something
like the symbol for the set of all real
numbers and you try and type the code
and then you get some kind of error well
that actually requires a package
some do use package
and the name of the package that we're
going to want to use for that is Ams
fonts
that package is going to allow us to use
some specialized math notation so let me
come over here to my questions and then
add in before question number one uh
let's just say I we want something
something to do with all Runners I'm
just going to type this is the symbol
for all real numbers
and the uh code for that we have to be
in math mode we're going to backslash
math BB you can see that it's popping up
as a suggestion for me here and then
we're just going to put capital r closed
Math mode and compile and I will zoom in
over here so we can get a better view of
that but now we have there the symbol or
a misspelled symbol the symbol for all
real numbers
and we of course have other symbols that
we can use like the symbol for these set
of integers
so let me just copy that
the symbol for
and I probably should say for the set of
yeah
let's do that properly
for
the set of integers
and that is going to be the capital z
and we can see that it produces that
symbol for us there we might want the
set of rational numbers
and that would be a q you get the idea
now if I didn't have this package loaded
I'm going to remove that and compile and
you'll see that I get an error it's
looking for when you see this undefined
control sequence it doesn't recognize
that command we do need to load a
package I don't know if it tells me in
the error message that which package I
need but sometimes you will encounter
that so we want to make sure that we're
using that package and whenever I'm
creating a document I automatically load
the AMS fonts package whether I need it
or not because I never know when I'm
going to end up typing some
mathematicals you know symbol that might
require it and if you are not including
any options so you're not using the
square brackets to Define any specific
options then you can actually load
multiple packages all using one command
so here I can type for example AMS fonts
comma and then the name of another
package that I want to use so I
typically will load AMS fonts AMS
Sim
and what's the other one AMS math I
think
those three I just always when I start
my documents I load those three packages
just in case I end up needing them
and you know in the end if you
comment that out
and compile and everything looks fine
you didn't really need those packages
you can always just leave a commented
out or you can delete it from your code
but I always just keep it in it's not
harming anything
all right so you load your packages
again in the pre-ample that is before
the backslash begin document
now you can also load some macros in
your preamble so macros are used to
define your own custom latex commands
and there are a few macros that I use
often that I'm going to share with you
but before I do that let's just you know
look at how a macro might work in
general so let's say you're working on a
document and there's a little snippet of
code that you know that you're going to
use multiple times in your document
you can Define it once using a custom
latex command and then within the body
of your document whenever you want to
call that up you can just type that you
know command that you've created instead
of having to type the whole code so for
example let's just say we were we were
typing a paper and we were we knew that
we were going to be working with a
rational function
and having to type it several times
throughout the document so let's just
say that that function is
y equals
and then we've got the fraction X over
3x squared
plus X Plus 1.
okay now I'm in the Preamble right now
so compiling will probably give me an
error like it doesn't make sense to have
this up here I don't know that I've ever
tried doing that before yeah I did get I
did get an error because I'm trying to
type this before my begin document
doesn't like that but I just wanted to
establish that this is an equation in
fact let's move it on down
here just so we can take a look at it on
our document
doesn't look that great at the moment
if I want that to be a larger fraction I
can go with d Frac instead
and it would look more like that okay so
let's go ahead and set up our macro and
all we have to do is type backslash def
for Define we are going to define a new
command what do we want to call our
rational function maybe we'll just call
it backslash eq1 for equation one so
we're defining equation one and then in
curly brackets you're going to type the
code that you want the compiler to run
every time you type backslash eq1 inside
of your document so you're gonna have to
decide if you want to include the dollar
signs as part of the command or exclude
them I would say it's safer to exclude
them just in case you're in a situation
for example if you're doing an equation
array or you're in a begin a line of
environment where you don't want to use
dollar signs uh you might run into
issues there so I am going to omit the
dollar signs
and just type the actual equation part
there now when we do want to call up
this function within our document
we're going to have to type the dollar
signs so again you can decide if you
want to include the dollar signs or not
as part of the way that you have defined
this special command slash eq1
so now that it's defined we can use it
and it didn't look great just sitting
there above critical thinking questions
let's just make this a new item in our
list here
let's
examine
the function
backslash eq1 now again this is going to
be problematic because it's going to try
and display
equation one but it's not in math mode
so you can see if I compile it doesn't
like that it's telling me right I can
see right away oh you're missing a
dollar sign so we just have to put
dollar signs around our EQ one and we
should be good to go there we are
let's examine the phone so without
having to retype the equation I can just
call it up like this and then any at any
point throughout my document I can call
that up again quickly just using slash
eq1 so that can be helpful
let me show you
um some of the macros that I commonly
use in my documents I have this document
open
right here this is one that I use very
frequently
and this one again we're in the Preamble
is where we're defining these custom
commands so this one starts backslash
new command
and then the name of the command in
curly brackets
so this is the actual command that if I
were not using a macro I would just type
this out within the body of the document
whenever I want to use it and this is
going to increase the vertical space
between items in my list so it's adding
more separation if you want to think of
it that way the item set it's adding
separation between list items and
this pound one is for is where I am
going to input a value so each time I
this is this one is a little bit
different because it's not a a static
command that is going to be the same
every single time this one I have to
enter a value when I use this command
and this is the part in the code that's
telling me that I'm going to enter a
value right here where typically a
number would be so how do we use that
after my begin enumerate if I decide
that I want more space between my list
items I can just bring up this command
and I'm going to just type backslash set
like this
backslash set and then in curly brackets
I'm going to type how much space I want
so I can type the number one here let's
compile and that has added some space if
I want more space I could type the
number two
and that gave me even more space let's
just really exaggerate it I'm going to
type the number five
and that's giving me a lot of space
typically I normally just stick with
about 1.2 that's my my go-to unless I'm
trying to leave room maybe if I'm typing
a quiz I want to leave room for students
to write answers although I typically do
that with a V fill rather than the set
command
so that is one that I use often another
one that I use often let's go over here
um let's look at this one
now this one is going to require I
believe that we use a certain package
yeah we're gonna have to use our
packages you can see I have a lot of a
lot more packages loaded in this sample
document than the one we're working in
right now but let me go ahead our
commands go in the Preamble so I'm going
to put that one up here and this one is
going to insert a calculator symbol the
command that I would be typing is just
slash calculator but we are going to
want to use
these two packages tixi pgf plots
so I'll come back up here where I've
loaded all of my packages and let's
compile
or I haven't actually asked it to use
that command so let's try using it and
make sure it works so I'm just going to
right here let's say I want
um to let people know that this is a
calculator active question I can type
backslash
calculator
pile and then it's going to insert that
little calculator symbol now I need a
space between that and let's so I always
just put an extra backslash like so and
that's going to give me that little
extra space that I need there and so if
I'm typing up a set of homework problems
and my students know that they can use a
calculator on that particular question
so that um
is a really great use of this macro
because I don't want to have to type
this code every single time I want to
insert that calculator icon I just do it
once in the Preamble and then whenever I
want to use it I can just type the
backslash calculator so that's how you
do custom commands in latex okay and
then the last thing we're going to talk
about here is inserting Graphics now
it's important when you insert graphics
and by Graphics I mean image files jpegs
pngs are typically the ones that you're
going to be working with it's important
that you save those image files in the
same folder where you've saved your Tech
file so let me open my finder window
this is the folder where I've saved my
tech file this is the tech file we are
working on right now it is in this
folder
latex tutorial 6 packages macros and
Graphics so I'm going to find the image
that I want to use I've saved it to my
desktops to make it easy to find it's
right here so I'm going to copy that and
then I will come back here this is the
folder where my tech file is and I'm
going to paste that image file in this
folder they need to be in the same
folder for the compiler to find the
image otherwise you will get a compiling
error
so let's go back up top because we do
need to load a package in order to
insert images so the package that we're
going to use use package
graphic X graphic X that is the package
that we are going to use and then where
I want to insert my image let me go back
to a page width view here let's put the
image
right above question number one here
where's statement number one here we'll
put it before the enumerated list so in
between critical thinking questions I'm
going to insert my image right here and
the most basic way to insert this image
backslash include Graphics you can see
that the suggestion is popping up
the scale now I can go with a scale of
one I find that typically a scale of one
it sounds like it should be the right
size right because it's 100 percent
scale but it's usually really big so if
I do use scale I find that I normally
have to use a number between zero and
one but we'll we'll just try it and see
what happens so scale equals one and
then you type the name of your file so
let me go back to that folder because
I've forgotten the name of it so the
file is limit dot PNG
so here I'm going to type limit I don't
have to type the dot PNG you can it's
fine but you don't have to you can omit
the dot and then the file extension so
if I had a limit dot JPEG file I could
also just type limit and let's compile
and there is our image so it is bigger
than what I would like for this document
you can see the font size here on the
axis is a whole lot bigger than what I
have in the rest of the document so we
can
decrease the scale maybe try 0.8
still too big I mean let's go with 0.6
I typically don't use scale I typically
want to make sure that all of my images
have a consistent width or maybe a
consistent height so there is another
option for sizing your image besides
using scale you can specify the height
of your image you can specify the width
of your image so let's just do width
equals
and we will try five inches
okay so that's pretty big I don't know
why I went with that that big let's try
3.5 inches
now you can also specify the height
instead of the width or at the same time
so if you change the aspect ratio things
are going to look a little wonky let's
try height equals five inches
and you'll see that I haven't maintained
that aspect ratio so typically I just do
one or the other either width or height
you don't have to use inches you can use
centimeters you can also use percents so
we could say something like with equals
to do a percent you want to do something
like this zero let's if we want 50 we
could say 0.5 so slash text width so
that's going to make the width of the
image half of the text width
yeah that looks about half right if I
went with 0.75 that's going to be really
big because it's going to take up
three-fourths of the
um I can't say page width because it's
not including the margins but the text
width right so that's another way that
you can size your images there
and if you want something smaller now
it's only one-fourth of the text width
now if you want the image to be centered
let's go back to 0.4 if you want your
image to be centered and this is the way
that you're inserting your image then
before the image we can do backslash
begin Center
and after the image backslash end Center
so we don't want to Center everything on
the page we just want to Center the
image okay so that is the a really
simple way to get uh Graphics into your
document there's nothing fancy here we
don't have a caption you know labels any
of that kind of stuff so if you do want
to have a little more control maybe you
want to add a caption to your image or
you want to have a little more control
over the placement of your image then we
can put our image inside of
the figure environment so let me take
away begin and end Center because
there's a better way to do that if we
right before the image backslash
begin figure
and then right after the image backslash
and
figure
all right let's compile that
and you'll see that it moved the image
now in the code I've placed the image
between critical thinking questions and
my enumerated list
but the compiler moved the image and it
displayed it at the top of the page well
if if you don't like that you have some
options for telling it where to place
the image here we can do in square
brackets
in h for here place the image here now
that might not always work because
sometimes the compiler thinks it knows
better about where that image would fit
best like if there's not quite enough
space where you want to put it or I
honestly I don't know how it how it
decides exactly where to place the
images but sometimes even this lowercase
H doesn't work if you want it at the top
of the page you can use a t if you want
to place the image at the bottom of the
page you can use a b
that moved it down to the bottom of the
page but normally I want my image to be
right where I coded it and so I use a
capital H but if I try and compile this
I'm going to get an error because the
capital H requires a special package and
that
is the float package so that is one that
I almost always load in my documents in
case I need it because it is also really
useful for placing tables not just
images but also tables and so if you
load that flow package and you use the
capital H here it will put the image
right where you have the code for the
image
regardless of whether it fits well in
that space or not
and if you want to Center your image
then inside of that figure environment
you can just type slash
centering so that will Center the image
and also the caption if you use a
caption so if we want to place a caption
below the image I can end my line here
and type backslash caption
and then in the curly brackets type my
caption so this is
a visual or oh let's just call let's
just say this
The Squeeze theorem
now notice all I said was caption The
Squeeze theorem I never typed figure one
but look when it displayed the caption
it labeled or numbered this figure for
me automatically which is really nice if
you have several images in your paper
it's going to number them as you go and
then later if you go back and insert
another image it will automatically you
know reset all of the numbering and
number everything appropriately now for
those of you who are using overleaf
let's talk about how to insert an image
here so I've just copied and pasted the
code from my techmaker file over here
and when I hit compile I did get a
compiling error it looks like I have two
errors and it's because it can't find
the image I've asked it to include in
the document so it's looking for this
this file called limit and it can't find
it because I have not uploaded it here
into overleaf so you're going to want it
to appear in this list along with your
Tech file so here's our you know main
Tech file I can rename this if I want so
that it matches the other one tutorial
so you don't want to always have
main.tech be your file names here
because then when you start exporting
things to your computer you'll have
multiple Ted files that all have the
same name so I do like if you're using
overleaf get it in the habit of renaming
those files okay so we need to upload an
image and place it here in this list
so here is the icon to upload and then
you're going to find that image on your
computer you can drag and drop it into
the box I have that image on my desktop
so let me do that
I'm just going to drag it over here and
drop it
and it appears right here so now when I
compile it should work out
okay and there we go there is my image I
had no problems finding that file
because it is again in the same folder
here in the same directory as the tech
file itself
so that does it for this tutorial we
talked about loading packages we looked
at defining some custom commands and
then how to deal with inserting images
into our documents
I'm Michelle krummel and in this video
we are going to take a look at errors
and debugging so for errors I have
intentionally made some very common
errors and we're going to go through
them one by one and see if we can fix
them so I um haven't tried compiling
this document yet I'm going to go ahead
and compile it
and when I do that I run into an error
so I'm not actually seeing PDF output
produced over here if the the file will
not compile
and so I have a number of errors and I
can see in my log down here I can scroll
through I have all kinds of errors and
it's telling me it's giving me some
Clues as to where these errors are and
then what types of Errors they are so
having the line numbers is very helpful
and if you're not seeing your line
numbers appear here you can go into your
tech maker preferences and make sure you
have line numbering turned on in your
editor so that is a check box right here
that you can select or deselect but I
like having the line numbers show
because it really does help when you're
trying to find errors
okay so let's look at that again now the
first error apparently is occurring on
line five and that's where my cursor is
at the moment so it kind of worked its
way through the file while it was trying
to compile
and there's a problem here on line five
so the first thing I like to do is just
read it very carefully and see if
anything jumps out at me and I can you
know make sometimes I'll just notice oh
I see the mistake that I made there
you know we're starting with double
dollar signs we're closing with double
dollar signs that's not an issue I have
my left parentheses now whenever you use
a slash left you need a matching slash
right and I'm noticing I don't have a
slash right so that's probably the issue
and if we read the actual error it says
right here missing slash right so that's
a big clue to me to let me know what
kind of mistake it is I'm dealing with
so I do have clothing parentheses or
parenthesis right here but I did not
type slash right in front of it
okay so I'm going to try compiling again
to see if that fixed the error
now it still did not successfully
compile but that's because there are
other errors in the document I can tell
that I've fixed the error in line five
because now when I look down at my error
log the first error is occurring on line
eight so we fix the problem in line five
now let's deal with line eight notice we
don't actually have any code in line
eight so when that happens I usually go
to the line right before it and and look
for an error there
another good tip when you're trying to
troubleshoot here or debug your code if
there are too many errors or you're just
not sure exactly where their error is
you can have the compiler temporarily
ignore part of your code by commenting
it out so anything you want to comment
out you can type a percent symbol in
front of it notice that this turned gray
the line turned gray the compiler is
going to completely ignore everything on
line nine so sometimes you'll want to
use that strategy just to narrow down
where the error is
now we the log says it's on line eight I
know it's not actually on line eight
so what I'm going to do just to show you
how you can use this commenting thing
I'm going to comment everything out
except for endocument I don't want to
comment that out because we have a begin
document we need an end document or it's
never going to compile so I highlighted
everything else here and I can go
individually and type percent symbols
but there is a keyboard shortcut I can
type command t on my Mac and that will
comment all of the lines that I've
highlighted alternatively you can come
up here to edit and choose comment and
it will do the same thing now I've just
done it twice so I'm going to I think if
I undo it'll only do one line so let me
do edit and uncomment to okay there we
go
so now the only code that is going to
run when I compile is the lines that are
not grayed out here and I know that I
fixed the error in line five so let's
see what happens
okay now it's just giving me errors on
line eight supposedly line eight but I
know for sure that it's happening right
here because everything after that is
being ignored and everything before that
we have fixed
so let's take a look at this and see if
we can pinpoint what's missing the
dollar signs look okay A lot of times
um there's a missing dollar sign and
that's an a common error that you can
make but I'm noticing you know for every
opening dollar sign I have closing
dollar signs so that's good slash Frack
I've got curly brackets around the
numerator ah but I don't have curly
brackets around the numerator because I
accidentally typed parentheses here
instead of the curly bracket so let's
change that to a curly bracket now I
think I've fixed it so I'm going to try
compiling again
and success the the file did compile now
I've hidden all this other stuff so it's
not showing
so what I can do now is just unhide
these lines one at a time I can
uncomment
uh them and back and then try and
compile
and we have an error now on line nine if
I look at the error it says missing
curly bracket so that's probably what
the problem is and I sometimes I will
count this is open number one open
number two close number one
open number three
closed number two oh what did I just do
there
we go let's try that again actually when
I'm doing this because it's hard to to
kind of keep track I'll count all the
open uh curly brackets and then all the
closing curly brackets so I have open
one
two
three
I have three opening ones and then let's
look for the closing ones
we've got one
and then two so I know that I'm missing
a curly bracket somewhere now notice the
color coding that's going on to help me
if I put my cursor right after a closing
curly bracket it shows me the pair it
shows me the one that's opening and then
being closed by this bracket
so that's that pair is good this pair is
good when I click here nothing nothing
got highlighted like up here if I put my
cursor next to that it's going to
highlight the pair but when I put my
cursor here it's not highlighting a pair
so this opening one right here is
missing a closing one so then you're
going to look at your code and see
okay where does the square root end and
that means I have to put one at the end
right here and now I've got that pair
highlighted so let's compile and see if
that worked that did work so that was
successful
let me go ahead and zoom in here
okay so now I'm not going to just
uncomment begin enumerate because that
would certainly give me an error
whenever you have a begin you need an
end
okay but now I don't I think I might get
an error here because I'm saying hey I'm
making an enumerated list but then I
didn't put any items in my list so you
need at least one item
and if we compile that works there's my
first item so I'm just going to take a
chance maybe there's no errors in here
and I'm going to highlight all of this
and to uncomment them all back I can hit
command U on my keyboard or I could have
gone up here to edit uncomment and it
would have the same effect and now we
will compile that and I am getting an
error so I know there's an error
somewhere here
okay so let's see if we can figure out
what it is
we've got the second item that looks
fine begin enumerate and anytime you see
begin something ask yourself do you have
a matching end and I don't because the
end enumerate right here matches the
begin enumerate right here so this
beginner numerate does not have an end
enumerate
so I need to come down right here
and add an end enumerate that's a common
error that happens especially when
you're making nested lists and now
everything is okay indenting can help
with this if you don't indent and you
have everything like this then it's hard
to see which begin enumerate is paired
with which and denumerate it's a lot
easier if you indent and you can indent
a bunch of lines at once if you
highlight them and then
for my Mac it's command shift and then
the
right angular bracket on the keyboard
the one where you uh same key you hit
for a period and you can do that
multiple times if you want to indent
more and if you want to go in the other
direction you can use the left angular
bracket to go the other direction
okay so then let's comment out this next
part
and see if there's an issue there also
I'm going to try compiling
nope I've got a problem here
and I'm if I read the error message it
says undefined control sequence so
undefined control sequence often happens
if you well the compiler doesn't
recognize a command so you typed
backslash something and it doesn't
recognize it and the most common reason
common two reasons for that are one the
commands you're trying to use requires a
package that you don't have loaded or
two there's a typo in your command you
accidentally misspelled it which is the
case here because I meant frack and I
spelled farc so we'll change that to
frack and see if that fixes that and it
does there's my fraction there I'm going
to go ahead and just uncomment all the
rest of this stuff
and we'll see how many more errors we
have in this file
okay scrolling down here it looks like
we still have quite a few
so I'm good up to line 24 even though
it's telling me that the next error is
on line 26 missing dollar sign inserted
and I can see right away that it's a
dollar sign issue because remember when
you open Math mode using a dollar sign
everything in math mode turns green and
looking at this there is way too much
green here too many things are green
that aren't supposed to be green only
the math should be green
so this text if that discriminant that
should not be green so I forgot to close
my dollar sign right here
and as soon as I type that dollar sign
you can see that that text now turned
black which is how it's supposed to be
so let's try compiling
now I still have errors in the document
so it did not update the PDF this is the
PDF from the last successful compile
that we did
so be aware of that as well if you feel
like you're clicking compile and
nothing's changing over here it could be
because you have a compiling error and
it's not updating your PDF for you
and you can turn these this message log
off so if you're not you know maybe you
wouldn't realize that you had an error
your PDF is just not updating but for me
the message log automatically pops up
when I have errors okay so now let's
look at line 27 and see if we can figure
out what issue we're having here so in
the Align environment
first of all I noticed something's weird
because it's colored in a strange way
I'm expecting the math to be green and
things that aren't math to be black but
this stuff right here I clicked a dollar
sign to start Math mode
but this is black why isn't it green if
it's in math mode well when you're when
you start the a line environment here
when you type backslash begin a line
it's it automatically puts that in math
mode so I'm in math mode before I ever
type anything when I do begin a line
like that I'm in math mode right now so
if I start typing you'll see it's green
because it is in math mode now let me go
back to what I had
so what happened when I typed the dollar
sign is it actually closed the math mode
and that's causing me errors here so
when you're working in a line never use
the dollar symbols
you're automatically in math mode now
things look a bit more normal the math
mode is green like I would expect it to
be so let's compile
and we still have an error it's still
saying line 27. now obviously the
problem is not on line 27 because
there's nothing wrong with this code
right here the syntax but it's
something to do with my align
environment here
if you look at the other code messages
that are popping up so sometimes this
will give you a clue as to what's wrong
and other times you know maybe it's not
you're not real sure what this means
miss it looks like missing dollar sign
inserted but that's not really what the
issue is here misplaced alignment tab
character that's talking about the
Ampersand that's not the issue here the
issue here is that we have a blank line
in our align environment and typically
blank lines don't matter at all you can
put as many blank lines in your code as
you want
it's not an issue it's not even going to
show up as blank lines over here on your
document in fact the compiler ignores
spaces as well I don't know that I've
mentioned that yet
so not in text I don't not in text mode
in text mode Let's see what happens if I
put a bunch of spaces here actually I
think it probably will still ignore it
oh let me hide this because it won't
compile so there's an error there so I'm
commenting that out so we can see what
happens here when I put in all these
spaces
there and look here then there are no
real Roots it ignored all of those
spaces you can type as many spaces as
you want here and it's going to ignore
it which is kind of nice because
sometimes when you're you have a lot of
code
it's helpful to your eye to space things
out for example up here where we have
the square root
especially when you're trying to find an
error in fix and error sometimes I'll
come in here and I will just put a bunch
of space like I know the slash square
root goes with that closing bracket
right there and I'll just put a bunch of
spaces just to visually separate it so I
can focus on the interior because if I'm
sure that this looks correct and it's
matching with this right here then I
don't need to focus on that part of the
command I I really want to just focus
what's in the middle here so spacing
things out in your code can be helpful
and this absolutely will not affect your
output the compiler will ignore spaces
sometimes it's frustrating frustrating
because you want a space and it's
ignoring the space when you type it but
there is a way to hard code a space if I
want to put a spacer I can just do
backslash comma
and then I could do that as many times
as I want so let's insert some spaces
here and now when I compile I should see
the square root symbol and then a weird
amount of space and then my fraction so
that's happening right here I've
inserted some extra space there let's
take that away because that's not proper
okay and now it looks normal again
so let's go back to trying to fix our
issue here and I think I already told
you what the problem was in an align
environment you cannot have an empty a
blank line you cannot have a blank line
so let's remove the blank line
and try compiling
and oh I still have another error okay I
thought that was going to work okay so
I'm not getting any any good Clues from
the message here so I'm going to look at
the code very carefully and make sure I
didn't misspell something make sure that
I have all the matching stuff that I
need everything looks good so my next
uh thing to check is is there a package
missing that maybe I need
so at this point I'm not sure what the
issue is I always go to Google Google is
your best friend when you are trying to
troubleshoot latex errors so I am just
going to
Google's you know some kind of words
that are going to indicate what my
problem is so latex and then begin a
line and let's see I think it's a
package issue so let's see what pops up
so a couple of Clues here I'm seeing use
AMS math use package AMS math the very
first hit aligning equations with AMS
math so I think that was the package I
needed and not that float package so
let's come back up here and try AMS math
AMS math
and compile and sure enough that fixed
the issue so that was the package I
needed and I think I mentioned this in
an earlier video whenever I create a
document I always load AMS math
AMS Sim and AMS fonts because I can
never remember which one does what and I
frequently need to use these three
packages so just out of habit I go ahead
and load those packages for all of my
latex documents
so that fixed the issue that we were
having here
okay so uh fixing errors you know it can
be frustrating certainly but you want to
try
um just a systematic approach to it use
that tip I showed you about commenting
out parts of the code so you can really
narrow in right where the error is use
that error log to help provide clues to
you so you can see what the error is and
before we go let's just hop on over to
overleaf and I'll show you what
debugging looks like in overleaf it's a
little bit different
to be honest with you it uh it's not
very pleasant okay and I think I made
this sample document it was a copy of
our tutorial with all of these errors in
it so the reason I said it's not very
pleasant is just because you see all of
this red like it just induces panic when
I see this I'm typing on a document and
then things all of a sudden turn red
right it's very jarring but it's showing
me that I do have issues now in overleaf
so I'm trying to compile it's not
compiling clearly I'm having a problem
because everything turned red it's
giving me some indication of maybe what
the problems are but but you see that
it's not quite as
um
explicit as it was in tech maker where
it said line five and then line eight
and then line nine we are getting a
little clue right here this l.5 is
referring to line five
uh and it looks like slash right it's
also identifying what the problem might
be there you really have to read these
read these and look for Clues
uh and then also this red X right here
is indicating that we have an error on
this line so we're going to try and fix
it if you remember from last time the
problem was we were missing the slash
right in front of this other bracketing
symbol
okay now as soon as I fixed that notice
what happened the Red X in front of line
five disappeared but now I've got all
these other red X's so these are
indicating other problems now this one
doesn't make a whole lot of sense
uh backslash begin document like that's
there's nothing wrong with that but if
we hover over this and look at the
message it's saying it's unclosed in
other words like we have a begin
document but we don't have an end
document well clearly we do have an
endocument it's down here
but look what it says down here
hey I found an unexpected end document
after a begin enumerate so it's it's
seeing this slash end and trying to
close and enumerate so now I'm kind of
piecing together the actual problem it's
not the begin document it's not the end
document it has something to do with a
begin enumerate that probably wasn't
closed and I have to really like hunt
through here look very carefully at all
my beginner numerates and make sure they
have matching end in new rights and if
you remember this one does not so it's a
little harder I think to troubleshoot
this problem in overleaf
slash end
enumerate and you can see as I'm fixing
things some of that red is going away
it's not panicking quite as much but now
we have other coloring issues going on
and oh things are turning red again
that's not cool uh
oh now we have a warning here this
symbol is just a warning it's not
necessarily going to cause a compiling
error
and if you read the message it's telling
us something about the end of line which
is happening all the way down here so to
me like debugging an overleaf is
definitely not as easy as it is in tech
maker and I would highly suggest if
you're working an overleaf that you use
that strategy of commenting out a large
chunk of your code so that you can
really focus on one little section at a
time but before you even get to this
point the best piece of advice I have
for you I can't believe I haven't said
it before now in this video but the best
way to
prevent errors or to to debug errors is
to compile all the time compile
frequently right after you type a line
of code compile and so you can see oh
that works no errors keep going type A
next little bit of code compiled don't
try and type your whole document and
then hit compile and end up with 25
errors then it's a nightmare to try and
fix them all so compile as you go
frequently every line every couple of
lines hit that compile button and make
sure that everything is running properly
okay I'm not going to go through fixing
all the rest of these because we already
saw how to do that how to fix them but I
I did want to show you what the
interface is like over here
um even though it's tempting to fix them
just to get rid of all of this red here
I'm Michelle crumble and in this video
I'm going to show you some tips for
using tech maker and some tips for using
overleaf
so we're going to get started by opening
up a tech file that I've already created
techmaker is set to be the default
program that will open Tech files that
are stored on my computer so if I double
click on this file it's automatically
going to launch techmaker and open the
file within techmaker so here is a file
and this is what our tech maker window
looks like yours might look a little
different because I I may have changed
some options some of my viewing options
so in terms of what you see on the
screen right now you can change that
with these four buttons at the bottom if
we open up the structure panel over here
we see first of all our file structure
and right now I just have the my my tech
file here I don't have anything else
added in here if I click on some of
these other buttons we're going to see a
list of symbols and if I click on one of
these symbols it's going to insert the
code for that symbol so I want to think
about where I'm going to insert this
let's just insert it at the end of this
first list item so this particular
symbol requires Math mode so I'm going
to hit dollar sign and then let's say I
forgot the symbol for plus or minus I
can come over here click on plus or
minus and it's going to insert the code
for that symbol for me right here and
now when I compile I should see the plus
or minus appear so to compile my
document I have a few options
what I usually use is just F1 F1 is
keyboard shortcut that is going to run
the code for me so I hit F1 on my
keyboard and my document compiles and I
can see the result over here and sure
enough I've got that plus or minus
symbol right over here another way that
I can compile my code is using the quick
build option up here and in this drop
down menu you can decide what's going to
happen when you press on this Arrow so I
like to have it set to Quick Build and
quick build is going to do two things
it's going to run the code it's going to
turn it into the PDF and then it's going
to show me the PDF
so we can change what quick build is
doing in our preferences if we go to
tech maker preferences quick build right
now when I run quick build when I press
quick build it's going to run PDF latex
view PDF so you can see that there are
quite a few other options that you could
select instead but this is probably the
one that you're going to want to use so
I would hit this Arrow right here and
that like I said is going to run the
code and then show me the PDF
now if I let's say I take away the plus
or minus
okay so now when I run my code it should
remove that plus or minus symbol and I
should not see it on my PDF if I come
over here view PDF and I click that
nothing changed I still have the plus or
minus there even though it's not over
here in the code and that's because view
PDF does not recompile your document it
only shows you the PDF from the last
successful compile I have not recompiled
so just clicking on this Arrow right
here is not going to do anything but
show you the PDF from the last time you
compiled it's not going to recompile so
you have to make sure you're clicking on
this Arrow
not this one over here click on this one
or like I said use your keyboard
shortcut of F1 and that recompiles and
we can see the plus or minus symbol has
disappeared so you have other categories
of symbols over here we've got arrows
different symbols brackets Greek letters
most used symbols this is going to
populate automatically based on what
you've clicked on in the past
and then we've got our favorites the
star here is a place where you can store
your favorite symbols so if there is
something that you think you'll use
frequently maybe I don't know I'll just
use this summation symbol you can right
click add to favorites and then you can
quickly find it by clicking on that star
icon and then just choosing it over here
if I click on this it's going to insert
that into the code but I don't actually
want that there
okay I'm going to go ahead and close the
structure panel so I'm not using it so I
don't want it to take up space on my
screen we have some other
things that we can click on over here
to call up some other commands so if you
need to start a new section you can do
that this way and you can type the name
of the section that you want I'm not
sure where I left my cursor so this is
probably going to put it in a bad place
in fact let me cancel let's say I want
to create a section right here so I can
go to section and I don't know what I
want to call it
section one
and I'll hit OK and it's going to insert
the code there to start this section for
me and then if I compile we can see that
it added section one for me there
you have other options that you can use
just click on here to see what you've
got all of your different font sizes
this one can be helpful it's hard to
remember sometimes what the smaller font
sizes commands are
if you want to use this one right here
to make something bold you want to
highlight the text first so let's say I
want to have chain rule in bold I would
highlight chain Rule and then I would
click on the B and you can see that it
inserted slash text BF the curly
brackets and my text is inside so now
when I run my code
chain rule is in bold okay so that can
be a bit of a Time Saver
and same thing here with italics
emphasis is another way to do italics
here we've got some justification
symbols
this one and if you hover your mouse
over here it'll pop up a little box that
tells you what it's going to do so this
is going to insert a new line here we're
going to get dollar signs a pair of
dollar signs
Etc so you can look at these different
options a fraction is something that
people frequently use so that's handy to
have it right here in this toolbar same
with the square root but remember in
tech maker when you start typing a
command so let's say we want to square
root
with open Math mode with a dollar sign
if I start typing backslash SQ it's
going to pop up some suggestions for me
so the top one would be for an nth root
and the bottom one would just be as for
a square root so that would give me the
square root of x so you can decide if
it's faster to just type it by hand or
maybe to click on some of the buttons
over here
before we look at some of the other
things in our menu so let's go ahead and
open the tech maker preferences and see
what we have going on there under this
commands tab
I just want to point out that you do
have the option with your PDF viewer to
use the built-in viewer or an external
viewer when you use the built-in viewer
that's what allows the PDF to show up in
this pane over here on the right which
again you can toggle on and off at will
if I switch to an external viewer let me
go back into my preferences if I switch
to an external viewer and it's one or
the other you can't have both selected
the external viewer is going to when I
ask to view the PDF it's going to open
it up in a different application outside
of techmaker so by default my computer
uses Adobe Reader to open PDFs so I'm
pretty sure that's what where it's going
to open so now you'll notice I don't
have the option to view the PDF in a
pane over here that went away so now
when I want to view my PDF so I can
quick build remember we'll also run view
PDF or if I just want to view the last
successful PDF I can click here and that
popped open in Adobe Reader
so there's my PDF I prefer to have the
built-in PDF viewer
because I'm constantly looking at my PDF
I'm constantly compiling as I work
to make sure that I catch any errors
right when they happen
so let me go back into my preferences
and go back to that built-in viewer
if you use something other than Adobe
Acrobat you can always change the path
here so click on this folder and then
just go into your applications folder
and find that executable file that will
launch whatever PDF reader you have
installed okay so let's move on to quick
build actually nothing new to talk about
here I showed you how you can change the
setting but I'm
confident that this is the one that most
of you are going to want to use
under the editor
if you change the font family or the
font size here it's not going to affect
your PDF output it's only going to
affect this little text editor part of
your screen okay so it's not going to
affect what's put on your PDF output
document now for the purposes of this
video tutorial I made my font size
pretty large 24 point is pretty large
because I wanted you to be able to see
the text clearly when I'm working I
normally work with it at size 16 so
that's more comfortable for my eye and I
can see more of the code on my screen
this is normally the font size I work in
but again you can change this you can
make it smaller you can make it larger
so when I'm recording videos I like to
set it to 24.
there are some options over here for you
to consider word wrapping I like to have
word wrapping turned on so in my text
editor
let's slide this over
here
uh we'll just slide that over some more
when I get you know when I run out of
room here it's just going to wrap down
to the next line so I like that because
I always want to see all of my code on
the screen but it does make the this
file take up a lot more space on the
screen so if that's not something you
want you can turn off the word wrap
completion so this is that auto
completion like when I started typing
the code for a square root and it popped
up the suggestion on how it thought I
might want to complete that command then
you just hit enter when you like the
suggestion so that is
um I find that to be a Time Saver I like
having the completion turned on show
line numbers is also really useful
especially when you are trying to debug
your code because an error message will
come up and tell you hey there's an
error on line 14 and then it's very easy
to find that in your code you can just
go right to line 14 and see the code
you'll notice that some lines don't have
numbers next to them and that's because
of the word wrapping so this technically
this part right here it's not going to
let me click on it because I have this
other window open this where it says to
solve this is not a separate line it's
part of the previous line so it doesn't
get numbered as a new line versus this
empty line here you know I had to hit
return to get to this empty line and
then return again to get to this line so
even though there's nothing there this
does count as a line number okay back
over to our preferences here back up
your document every 10 minutes you can
certainly turn that on if that's
important to you the reason I don't have
that turned on is because when you do
have this turned on then for all of the
files you're working in it the compiler
is going to or the program is going to
create this extra file it's going to be
also called tutorial 8 and it'll have
the extension bank so in your folder
let's see if I still have that fold yep
in the folder here there would be
another file that says tutorial
underscore 08.bak and my folders I just
feel like I have a lot of files them in
them as is and I don't like having that
extra file in there but it's no big deal
if you want the safety of backing up
your document every 10 minutes you can
do that I almost always recompile more
frequently than 10 minutes so it's not
really useful for me because every time
you compile it's going to save that file
on your computer so that acts as backing
up every so often as well now this is a
good time to point out when I first
launched this file
these this
tutorial8.aux.log and this dot syntax
dot gz we're not here the only thing
that was in here was this CMG project
and then the tech file and the PDF but
while you are compiling your file these
other auxiliary files are being created
these helper files are being created and
they will stay in there and they will
clutter up your folders and you really
don't need them once I close uh tech
maker I'm going to show you I'm just
going to come in here and close tech oh
it's not going to let me
because I have this window open
okay
so now let me try closed techmaker and
look those helper files disappeared that
doesn't happen automatically that only
happens because I set that up in my
preferences to happen that way but it
helps just clean up the folder so I
don't have a lot of extra unneeded files
cluttering up my folders so let me
launch this again I'm just going to
double click on this
to open that up and if we look at that
we see we just have these two files but
now if I compile
or I could have actually I could have
stayed on this no I couldn't off there
we go okay so now we've got all those
helper files in there so how do we
change that setting to get rid of those
helper files when we don't need them in
your preferences
right here you're going to make sure
this box is checked launch the clean
tool when exiting techmaker so when you
X Out of the program it's going to
remove those extra files that are not
needed
okay so
um we were looking at the editor window
tap with number of spaces you can
increase or decrease that as you like so
that would be when I'm working on my
code and I want to indent by hitting tab
that's just how many spaces it will
indent so you can customize that you can
change the color of certain things so
you'll have to know the hex code for the
color that you want this is white
so the background that I'm working in
again it's not going to affect your PDF
output it's just this editor panel here
where you're typing your code if you
want the white background there's a dark
theme and there's a light theme so if
you like working uh with like white text
on a black background you can go with
the Dark theme
or I don't know if it's white text
actually I don't typically use the Dark
theme but right now the background color
is set to White
are the
highlighted line
I forget what color that is that might
be correct I don't remember this is
black
this is gray
um this is green so the when you're in
math mode it's going to show up as green
so you can customize that if you don't
like the default colors you can come in
here and change the hex code
okay and then the shortcuts tab here is
just going to give you a list of
keyboard shortcuts and if there's
something that you find you're doing
frequently and there's not already a
keyboard shortcut for it you can add a
keyboard shortcut for it so the things
that say none
you can click on that and then you can
Define your own custom keyboard shortcut
all right so that takes care of
preferences
and we've looked at the this toolbar uh
we sort of talked about the important
stuff on this toolbar what have we got
up here so tech maker this is where we
found preferences if you're on the
Windows version you may have to go to
options to find preferences at least
that's the way it used to be but on the
Mac it's tech maker and then preferences
file we've got uh standard stuff here
edit these four commands are very
helpful and I use the keyboard shortcuts
for these all the time so if you want to
comment out a line
let's say for example I don't want these
last four items in my list to show up on
my PDF
I can use the keyboard shortcut which is
command T and it's going to put a
percent sign at the beginning of each
line and so by line I mean the number
line is where they're numbered and then
when I click off of that you'll see that
it also changed the color to gray so it
that's another indication to me that
something is commented out and what we
mean by commented out is that the
compiler will ignore that line of code
it will not even consider it when it is
running your code it's just going to
ignore it when it gets to that line
that's been commented out so one use of
commenting things out is you know maybe
you don't want something in your
document let's compile
so there I just got rid of some of those
questions but you don't want to delete
it because maybe you're uncertain and
you're you you want to show it later on
so I do that sometimes when I'm writing
a quiz or a test I have a question that
I decide to Omit but I don't want to
delete it because I think well maybe in
the future or if I'm making
um a makeup test I might want to then
turn on that question so that's a good
way if you're troubleshooting and you're
trying to figure out where an error is
commenting out a bunch of lines can
really help you pinpoint exactly where
the problem is and help you fix it
now to undo that to a bunch of lines at
once we can use the keyboard shortcut
command U and that will make them all
visible again
another use for comments is just to
leave little reminders for yourself
especially when you're first learning
latex maybe you don't you know remember
what a certain piece of code means this
for example on line three
will remove paragraph indenting so I
could leave a comment here for myself I
just go to the end of the line not the
beginning because then I won't run the
code at the end of the line time type
your percent symbol and make a note so
this will
remove the indents and it doesn't
necessarily have to remove the indent
but the zero is going to cause it to
have an indent of zero space so I could
put a number there instead if I wanted
10 ex is a unit of measure
then that would give me large indents
but I typically turn off indenting in my
documents so another good use for
comments there
indent indent indent and unindent would
be not for the PDF output
not to confuse you because I was just
talking about indenting here this is the
code that will affect the indenting in
your output document but sometimes you
want to indent your code so maybe we
want to indent these
lines right here I can do that all at
once if I hit and I'm on a Mac so it's
command shift and then the right angle
bracket and that will indent if I hit it
again
it will indent more so it's a good way
to organize your code make sure things
are lined up that all belong together
and you can undo that or reverse that
by command shift and then the left
angular bracket
and again if you forget the keyboard
shortcut you can always just access it
from the menu here or you can look and
see what the keyboard shortcut is from
the menu here under the latex
menu here you've got all kinds of
different options if you forget the code
for something you've got it right here
you can just click on it and it'll
insert the code for you I don't know
where my cursor is at the moment let's
put my cursor in a good place
well we'll just put it at the end of
that sentence there
okay so one that I find hard to remember
I have a lot of this stuff memorized but
one that I find hard to remember
sometimes are the international accents
and this comes up when I'm trying to
type l'hopital's role so for low vital's
role we need a special accent over the O
and this is the command right here
just put an O there so it's capital l
apostrophe h o but it's the accented o
will be tall
and then let's build that
and we can see it right there it's got
the special accent over the o
so the pull down menus are great for
things that you don't use too often you
don't remember what the code for them
are it is our math we have other menus
here
if you just kind of hover over you'll
see what's available there the wizard is
cool
um let's I'm going to just close this
document I'm not going to close tech
maker I just want to close this document
and let's start a new document so this
old PDF is just hanging out over here
just because I haven't recompiled
something yet so let's start a new
document so I'll just click the new and
you know we can start from scratch or we
can use this wizard to get started quick
start it's going to ask me for some
basic settings we want uh and to use the
document class article if you're doing a
slide presentation you would use Beamer
but we have article
and you've got some options here you
don't have to use any of these options
you can ignore that if you don't need it
I don't see anything here that I want
you can decide if you want to go 10 11
or 12 point let's go 12 point just so
this is a little bigger for the video
paper size you can choose the size of
paper that you would be printing on so
in the US we use letter paper
the author if you want to include that
if you know that you want to include
your name in your document
you can do that if you know the title of
your document I mean you probably do
this one that we're working on is
critical thinking question or we'll just
say IB math
analysis and approaches
HL
okay geometry package do you want to
load the geometry package that's pretty
useful and then you can specify all of
your margin sizes although I don't like
the ones that are being offered here
I would prefer one inch margins and if I
don't want to if I want them all to be
one inch I can just say margin
equals one inch AMS packages absolutely
I always include those the graphic X
package if you're going to have images
in your file so that one is useful and
that's all I need I'm going to hit OK
and I've got some basic stuff here to
get me started I usually like to space
out things a little bit here
after my packages I'll leave an empty
line
okay that looks good and if this I don't
know what's going to happen with the dot
here let's see if we get an error
yeah we do oh for but for a different
reason it won't compile your document if
you haven't saved it and named it
so you got that could not start the
command error it looks like hey I have
code here why aren't you compiling it
and it looks like it has a name but it
actually doesn't I have not saved this
file yet and named it so we have to do
that
so do file save as
and then sure let's keep put it in the
same folder tutorial underscore 08 B
and we'll save that okay so now my file
is named never never never never use
spaces in your file name you'll notice I
put the underscore there instead of
typing a space do not put spaces in your
in your Tech file names or your image
file names it can cause issues okay now
let's see if we can if this dot is gonna
still result in an error
it does not okay so sometimes people
message me and they're having and they
did something like this and then they
try and compile and they get an error oh
now it's not going to work because it
still remembers this but if that happens
to you the reason that you're getting a
compiling error here is because you
haven't actually typed anything between
your begin document and your end
document it looks like you know you have
typed a lot of stuff up here but this is
what we call the Preamble the part of
the code that comes before begin
document is just your Preamble it's like
pre-setting certain things up and
you can't run the code unless you
actually have something
in between your begin and end document
so even if it's something simple like
hello
and then we can run that and no issues
there
okay so quick build not quick build the
wizard quick wizard quick start there we
go quick start can be helpful way to get
you started from a blank document and
you've got an option to do a quick start
for a beamer presentation and some other
options as well if you want to insert a
table
you can also use the wizard there
quick tabular is going to bring up this
window and you can enter how many rows
and columns you want in your table and
you've got other options here if you
want to align the contents of your cells
left right or centered or if you want
them to be in like paragraph form if
you're not entering numeric values if
you're entering text you might want to
switch to a paragraph and where you
define the width of your columns there
you can also merge some columns and
decide if you want a border on the left
and the right and at the top and at the
bottom so you can have all of those or
none of those or some but not all and
you can check what you want there
um
you can add a vertical margin for each
row if you want that and when you click
on okay you can even come up here and
type I think can you type contents yeah
absolutely you can even type the
contents of your
table
now that should be in math mode
so tables can be a little bit tricky to
code by hand
so that's not cooperating
so this is really nice to have sort of a
visual way to create your table and then
you hit OK and it's going to insert the
code for you at least it's a good way to
get started you can add more columns you
I mean you can obviously edit this table
now in any way that you like
so let's take a look at that
there we are it's pretty simple
what else are we going to look at under
user I want to show you this this is
super helpful I use this all the time
you can
store bits of code and then just call
them up instantly so this is really
great when I am let's see which one do I
want to look at well if you want to add
your own you're going to go to edit user
tags and then click on one you can only
store up to ten so click on this one is
empty we could do a new one here or we
can just look at something I already
have so this is something that I use
often and I'm certainly not going to
have this code memorized but this is
going to insert a little calculator
symbol
so I often do this next to like
calculator active problems if I'm
assigning homework so I have this stored
Under menu eight and I can type the code
let's say
um I want the little graphing calculator
symbol right here so the command is
slash calculator
[Music]
and then I need to put the code for that
in the Preamble so I'm going to come up
here
now I can come up to user user tags and
then just either click here for
calculator icon or if I know the
keyboard shortcut it's just shift F
shift f8
so I can just do shift f8 and that
inserted all of these lines of code here
for me so I don't have to have them
memorized now I have lots of little code
Snippets that I use over and over again
and I only have 10 slots to store them
here in techmaker so what I actually do
is open Google Keep and I store all of
my code snippets on separate little
Google keep notes and so I can always
find them easily there as well that's
another tip for you
okay so that is looking good and now
when I run this I've got my little
calculator symbol in front of hello okay
view you can turn on and off different
uh toolbars
options help so notice under help you do
have access to a latex reference and a
user manual the user manual is going to
help you with tech maker specific
stuff that opens that up in a separate
window here but you can learn all about
tech maker and the different options and
if you're having trouble with some
aspect of tech maker that can be helpful
you also have the latex reference
which you can look up different types of
commands so if you want to learn more
about equation arrays you can click here
and then read more about equation arrays
and get some sample code and some
explanation on how that works or any
packages you might need like this one it
tells you you have to use the AMS math
package if you're going to use
in equation array so that can be a great
resource for you as well
okay let's switch over to overleaf and
I'll show you how to do a few things
here so I am logged in if I want to
start a new project I'm going to click
on new project blank project notice that
there are lots of templates available
though in the and overleaf has a
template library with with tons and tons
and tons of templates that you can use
so which is really great if you're
typing up a science lab report they have
some templates that you can start with
resumes all kinds of things but we're
just going to go with blank project
and we will again call this tutorial
eight
overleaf
and that's just the title of the project
but notice that when we create this
that's not the title of the file I told
you never never put spaces in your file
name and I did put spaces in the title
but that is not the name of the file the
name of the file is what we see right
over here main.tech
and I always recommend to my students
when they're using overleaf to change
the name of that file because every time
you start
a blank project in overleaf it's going
to call the file main.tech and so it
just gets confusing when you have lots
of files that are different but they're
all called main.tech so I always
recommend renaming that we'll call this
tutorial
8C there we go
and you can
um in this this pane is like the
structure pain that we had in Tech
makers so if you do add more files to
this project they will appear in the
list here
if you want to go back to the main menu
you would think that you should click on
menu but that is actually not going to
take you back to the main menu if you
want to go back to the main menu you
click on this Arrow right here and
that's going to take you back to this
main screen here so now to go back to my
project I can just click here and we've
got some basic code here to get us
started if you don't like what's here
you certainly can type over it or delete
it and start with something else you can
if you're loading a template you'll have
lots of code in here for you and you can
just edit it as you need to
so I'm not going to do much with the
code I just want to point out where
certain things are in overleaf and also
show you how you can download copies of
your Tech file and your PDF document in
case you need to send it to someone or
submit it to your teacher
this panel right here is just like in
techmaker is where we're typing our code
and you have the option to switch to the
Rich Text Editor I don't recommend this
but I guess it can be helpful if you're
really you know kind of unsure of what
something is going to look like and
maybe it's not compiling because there's
an error this might give you an idea of
what your work is going to look like but
I recommend sticking to source and just
working with the actual code here
when you're ready to run your code
you're going to click on recompile and
then it will refresh and show you your
PDF output over here on this panel if
you are working on a small screen and
you you know this is very tiny and you
can't see it very well you can also
collapse some of these paints so you can
click on right here
to go full screen and now it's just the
PDF so you get a nice big zoomed in view
of your work and then you can go back
split screen you can also drag this
separator to the left which will
increase the size here and has the same
effect as zooming in or you can drag it
to the right this side will get smaller
this side will get larger so you have
some options there you can also close
these panels using these little arrow
symbols right here so now I've hidden
that PDF panel and then I can bring it
back
like so if you want to share your
document and have multiple people
working in this same document you can do
that so here's what I recommend for my
students when you want to share a
document don't use this option here
where it says share with your
collaborators I mean intuitively it
seems like that's what you should do
right you type in someone's email
address and then you share it with them
well in the free version of overleaf you
are limited to how many people you can
collaborate with and so another option
instead of doing that would be to turn
on link sharing up here
turn on link sharing and then anyone
with the link can edit your project if
you share this link with them or anyone
with the link can view your project if
you share this URL with them okay so if
you are working in a group of four for
example this is the way you want to go
turn on your link sharing anyone with
the link can edit the project send your
collaborators this link and they will
all be able to work in the document with
you you can also turn on chat and so if
multiple people are working in the
document you can have a chat message
going on about certain things you also
have the option of commenting
commenting in techmaker is gray when you
comment here in overleaf it's this
bright blue so it's really easy to see
the con actually I like that maybe I'll
change that in my tech maker and make it
blue instead
um so it's easy to see comments that's
another way you can communicate with
people is by leaving comments in parts
of the code but the chat is another
option for you
okay let's say you're done with your
project and you want to download a copy
of your PDF so that is very easy to do
you just click on this icon right here
and it downloads the PDF for you
and then you can open that on your
device and it'll open in whatever PDF
viewer you normally use there's my PDF
and it downloaded it by default into my
downloads folder so I can find it there
on my computer
if you want to download your Tech file
that is not quite as easy in fact it's
much more difficult to do that
especially for my students who are
working on a Chromebook
but if you want to download
your Tech file you're going to come over
here and click on menu the thing that
you think would take you back to the
main menu but it doesn't so click on
menu and then you've got two options
here if you click on PDF it's going to
download the PDF but frankly the other
way to do it was easier or you can click
here that says Source that's what you're
going to want to do you want to click on
source and it's going to download not
your Tech file it's going to download a
zip folder and in that zip folder you
will find any of the files listed here
so if you've uploaded images or you have
multiple text files here or whatever
files here any files you have here that
are associated with this project when
you click on Source it's going to
download all of them in a single folder
and zip that folder and send you the
zipped folder so that folder is called
tutorial 8 overleaf that's the title of
my project dot zip now on a Mac this is
really easy to deal with so I just find
it I just clicked on on that and said
show in finder
but you can also just go to your
downloads folder and it's right here
tutorial 8 overleaf.zip all I have to do
on my Mac is double click on that and it
unzips it and actually when there's more
than one folder it looks a little
different so let's
let's go back here and add something
let's add an image in here I'm going to
upload
and I'm just going to drag an image from
my desktop
okay so I've added an image here and I
warned you not to have spaces in your
file name so I'm going to rename this
okay so now I have an image and a text
file and I'm going to I want to download
at least my tech file but really it
makes sense to download both because no
one can run your Tech file if they don't
have a copy of the image you'll get a
compiling error
okay so let's try this again
all I have to do is click on this and
it's going to
this was the zipped file
I already had one with the same name so
that's why I put the one at the end this
is the zipped file and when I double
clicked on it
it unzipped it or sometimes we call that
extracting
but now I just have a regular folder
this is not zipped anymore so when I
look inside that folder I see all of my
individual files I've got my tech file
and I have my image file what I don't
have here is my PDF this doesn't make
sense to me why don't they just don't
also include the PDF as part of this
that would be nice but you you if you
need both you're going to have to
download them separately okay so now you
have access this is in my downloads
folder I can move it anywhere else I
want to on my computer I can upload it
into Google Drive I can upload it into
my learning management system like
canvas
or really I can do anything I want with
it and to get back to our Tech file just
click on it and then that will make that
the active file again so I think that
covers everything I wanted to show you
in overleaf
and I hope you're able to use some of
these tips to help you work more
efficiently
hello and welcome to another video in my
latex tutorial Series today we're going
to be talking about some common notation
that you would see in calculus such as
limits integrals summations and Vector
notation
I'm starting with a very basic setup all
latex documents start with the command
backslash document class and I've set
this one up to be 11 point and the type
of document is an article
the only package I'll be using for this
tutorial is the geometry package and
that is simply to adjust the size of my
margin so that is optional you don't
have to use that
the body of our document will type in
between the commands slash begin
document and slash end document
I'm going to begin by identifying the
domain and range of a function
the function and now I want to enter
Math mode so I type my dollar sign
f of x
equals
and in parentheses I want x minus 3
squared so I raise that to the power 2.
plus one half
backslash frac
and tech maker is going to fill in the
rest of the command when I hit enter
and I can tab to get to the next part
and move my cursor outside of the braces
and let's go ahead and compile this and
make sure it looks the way we expect
remember when you open a new document
you must save it and give it a name
before you try and compile it or you
will get a compiling error
now I usually hit F1 as a keyboard
shortcut to compile my document but for
the sake of the tutorial I'll probably
move my cursor up here and build it by
pressing the arrow
that looks good we have the function f
of x equals the quantity x minus 3
squared plus one half
so I'm going to continue typing
has domain
and now to describe the domain
I want to name it with capital D and I'm
going to go into Math mode
I want a subscript of f because it's the
domain of function f colon
and
the domain for this function is all real
numbers now we do have the option of
using the symbol for all real numbers
but I'm going to use interval notation
so our domain goes from we're using it's
an open interval so parentheses negative
Infinity
negative we're just typing the minus key
on the calculator for the infinity it's
backslash i n f
t y That's negative Infinity comma and
now I want positive infinity or just
Infinity so backslash i n f t y close my
parentheses
and let's end Math mode and compile that
see what it looks like
okay now the one thing I would like to
change
is the D I don't want it to be
italicized because it's in math mode
letters are always going to be
italicized but I can make that not in
italics if I come back to my code and I
type I basically wrap it with the tag
math RM so backs go move your cursor in
front of the D
backslash math RM and then the curly
brackets around the D
now when we compile it our D should not
be italicized
but the F still is because it's outside
of those curly brackets
so let's finish by describing the range
so the function f of x has domain
from negative Infinity to Infinity
and range so I'm going to do something
very similar here I'm going to use a
capital R for the range so I'm going to
go into Math mode
but I don't want the r to be in italics
so backslash math RM
and in tech maker you can see it's
trying to complete the command for me so
if I hit enter it'll type the braces for
me and I can just type my r
r in the center there and use the right
arrow to come out of the braces
we want the subscript of f
colon and now our range goes from
one half to infinity and I do want to
include the one-half so I'm going to use
a square bracket around the one-half
to get the one-half I'm using the
command for a fraction
comma Infinity so backslash i n f t y
open parentheses
close Math mode
now let's typeset that and I have a
feeling I'm not going to be happy with
the way it looks let's try
okay so what I'm not happy about
is the square bracket here it's not
large enough to surround the fraction
one-half
so I explained this in an earlier video
on delimiters
but if we want to expand automatically
expand the size of the brackets or
braces or parentheses then we can
change the command slightly so I'm going
to find where those where that bracket
is so right here I'm going to put my
cursor in front of it and I'm going to
type slash left and that is going to
expand automatically fit that bracket to
the size of what comes after it and then
the parentheses on the right I also want
to
insert my cursor just before it and Taps
type slash right so if you use the slash
left
then you have to balance it somewhere
with a slash right the compiler will be
looking for that
okay so now we can see that both of
those delimiters have expanded
the other thing I might want to do
notice that the one-half is smaller than
the three
this has shrunk it to fit neatly on a
line because it's in line
if we wanted that to display at full
size we could go back and use
the display style command this doesn't
bother me I think it looks good the way
it is so we'll see how to use the
display style in a in another example
here in a moment
let's move on and look at how we can
type a limit
and I'm going to go ahead and end this
with two backslashes to give myself some
more space
and to type a limit the basic command in
math mode is backslash l i m
if I just end Math mode here and compile
you can see all we get is Lim and even
though we're in math mode these letters
are not in italics because the compiler
understands that this is a special
string of letters
now we want to adjust this we want to
take the limit of something
and we want to take the limit let's say
we want to take the limit as X
approaches a
I'm going to use another command
backslash limits
and that is going to be followed by
I'm trying to get as X approaches a so
underscore
and then in curly brackets
I want to type X and then an arrow and
then a so the symbol to get that right
arrow is backslash 2 t o
a and I'm going to close my curly
brackets and now we should see when we
compile it the limit as X approaches a
okay if I did not use this limits
take that out and recompile
as X approaches a will not be underneath
the Lim it will still be a subscript
because we used that underline but it's
going to appear to the right which you
may want I don't like it like that so
I'm going to go ahead and put the
backslash limits
command in front and now the
X approaches a will be underneath the
word limit
if I want to take the limit and we have
to take the limit of something so let's
come back and add our function in
general let's just call it f of x
so we want the limit as X approaches a
of f of x
if I want to take the left hand limit
the limit as X approaches a from the
left I just come back to my code and
after the a
use the carrot
you can type a plus if you want to
approach from the right hand side if I
want to approach from the left hand side
I'll type A minus
okay let's do one more example with
limits
we want the limit so backslash Lim and
to make the notation look a bit nicer
I'm going to use backslash limits
underscore
and I want again just the limit as X
approaches a so in my curly brackets X
backslash 2 t o
the limit as X approaches a
close my curly brackets
and this time I'm going to use the
definition of derivative at a point
so the limit as X approaches a of now I
want the fraction f of x minus F of a
over x minus a so backslash frac
in my numerator that's the first set of
curly braces or curly brackets
we're going to type f of x minus F of a
in the denominator so this goes in the
second pair of the curly brackets x
minus a
and that let's come outside of the
brackets there
is equal to F Prime of a so F and I'm
just hitting the apostrophe for that
Prime symbol of a
close my math mode Let's compile this
and see how it looks
all right I forgot to end my line with
two backslashes that'll give me a little
bit more space in between there
now this looks good but the fraction is
displaying rather small and that's
because it's trying to fit it nicely in
with the line but I want to make it look
normal size so I'm going to come back to
my command
and wrap the entire thing with display
style backslash
display Style
curly bracket and then at the very end
before the last before I exit Math mode
put the closing curly bracket and let's
compile this again
okay so now the fraction looks much
larger same size as the rest of the
notation
and that line with two backslashes and
now let's look at how to type set in
integral in math mode we're going to
start with backslash int for integral
let's take the integral of
sine of x now if I just type S i n when
I compile that it's going to be
italicized I don't want that so for sine
cosine tangent all the trig functions we
do backslash first so backslash s i n
of X and that should give me the
integral of sine X
now I also need my DX I can type DX just
like this close Math mode Let's see what
that looks like
now notice that the X and the DX are
kind of look like they're running
together there
so what I like to do here is just force
a space to be inserted between those
because remember just because you type
type a space over here in the code
doesn't mean it's going to appear as a
space when you compile your document but
to force a space right there I'm going
to hit backslash comma
so let's compile that and see if it
makes a difference
okay good so now there is a space
between my X and my DX now if you don't
want the d italicized we saw as we did
when we were typing domain and range how
we can wrap that lowercase D with the
backslash math RM tag and it wouldn't be
italicized but the italics don't bother
me with the DX so I'm going to leave it
like that
let's go ahead and solve this integral
so the integral of sine X DX equals
negative cosine X so I'm going to do
backslash cosine X now let's talk about
spacing for a moment over here I left a
space in between or in front of this
slash sign that's optional
I didn't over here but I did leave a
space between the S and the X here
otherwise the compiler might get
confused and think your command is
backslash cos x all is one thing so we
want to separate that with a space
and let's not forget R plus C very
important
and we'll compile that
and there we go
if I want my integral sign to be longer
so when you see it in a textbook you see
it online usually it doesn't look that
short and it's shrunk here to kind of
make it fit in that line neatly but we
can expand that
simply by using
display Style
so backslash
curly bracket and then just before we
end math mode put the closing curly
bracket
and that elongated that integral symbol
next let's look at a definite integral
so we also start with backslash int
that's the command for integral
but this time we need to show that we
want to take the integral from A to B
now I can simply use an underscore
and type a carrot B
let me close Math mode and see what that
looks like
okay so that gives me the short integral
but it is going from A to B and my lower
limit and upper limit of integration
appear to the right of the integral
symbol we can also
use backslash int with the backslash
limits command
underscore
a carrot B
and now we have
an integral where the A and the B are
not to the right of the integral symbol
but they're above and below the symbol
so you can decide which one of those you
prefer if you want the integral symbol
elongated simply wrap it with display
Style
I'm going to just copy
those last two commands and we'll see
what they look with display Style
in front
okay so we get logger integrals which
sometimes looks nicer let's continue
working with our definite integral
to talk about some problems you may
encounter along the way
if you're one of your limits is more
than one character then just using the
carrot is not going to be sufficient so
for example
let's say for some reason you wanted to
go from
2A to B let's see what happens when we
compile this
okay that's probably not what you were
expecting to see
so the what we're going to do to fix
this
is after the underscore the lower limit
you want to wrap that in braces or curly
brackets
and then we can do the same for the
upper limit now if it's just a single
character it's not going to be a problem
but if you have more than one character
you will need to do that so just to be
on the safe side you can always use the
curly brackets then you shouldn't run
into any trouble there so now we have
our integral with the lower limit of 2A
and the upper limit of B let's go back
to Just A and B I'm going to keep the
braces
okay now I'm moving my cursor in front
of the last
curly bracket because that goes with the
display style command
so let's take the integral of something
let's take the the integral of x squared
DX and remember I want to insert a space
just typing a space is not going to
insert a space when I compile this so
I'm going to use backslash comma DX
and we'll compile that make sure it
looks good so we have the integral of x
squared DX from A to B
and that is equal to
now there are a couple different
notations you might see for evaluating a
definite integral I usually use the
square brackets around the expression so
I'm going to type
the square bracket for the left side
when we integrate this the
antiderivative for x squared is X cubed
over three so I could write 1 3 x cubed
I'm just going to go ahead and write X
cubed over 3 so I want the fraction
x cubed
over 3. because this is a definite
integral we need to input our lower
limit and upper limit so let me
end with a square bracket
and then to get my limits on there I'm
going to use the underscore
and then lower limit of a
carrot upper limit of B so again if it's
a single character you don't have to
wrap it with the curly brackets
but to be on the safe side we can go
ahead and do that and just so you're
familiar with the notation
okay now let's see what we what that
looks like because I have a fraction I
have a feeling I'm not going to be happy
with the brackets
okay so the lower limit and upper limit
do appear in the correct place in
relation to the bracket but the bracket
needs to be expanded to the height of
the fraction so I'm going to go back
where I typed my opening square bracket
and in front of that backslash left
where I typed my closing square bracket
in front of that I type backslash right
and we'll compile that and that looks
much better
and let's go ahead and
finish evaluating our integral here so
that is equal to backslash fraction
B Cubed in the numerator
over 3 in the denominator and I need to
move my cursor to the right
so that I'm outside of that first
fraction
and now it's minus we plug in our lower
limit of a so I need another fraction
backslash Frac our numerator is a to the
power 3 denominator 3. let's compile
that
the next thing we're going to look at is
summation notation
to get the capital Sigma we're going to
use the command backslash sum
if I compile that
it's going to be pretty short
so usually that is written much larger
than the text beside it so we can make
it larger using
display style backslash
play style curly bracket and we go to
the end and put the closing curly
bracket if I compile that
now you can see the size is much larger
we want our sum to go from n equals 1 to
Infinity I'm going to use backslash
limits so I'm going to use then an
underscore
and on the bottom I want n equals one
that's not a single character so this
time I have to use the curly brackets n
equals one
close the curly brackets use the carrot
and now we're going to type our upper
bound so this time I want to go to
Infinity
so in the curly brackets I'm going to
type backslash i n f t y and close the
brackets
let's compile and see what we have there
okay so we have the sum
from n equals 1 to infinity and let's
keep going with that I need to be in
front of the last curly bracket because
that closes the display Style
and we want to take let's see the sum of
let's do geometric series a times R to
the power n and that is equal to let's
go ahead and compile so we can see where
we are
I'm going to go ahead and expand that
sum
so that is equal to a plus
a times R Plus
a times r squared
Plus
now I want dot dot dot
plus my nth term a times R to the power
n let's compile and see what we have I
have the dot dot dot but the dot dot dot
should be centered vertically so that
it's kind of aligned with the horizontal
crossbar of the plus sign and instead of
typing dot dot dot there's a command for
the three dots
I don't need to insert space between it
but just to keep the code nice and clean
I will and that command is slash if you
just want a single dot it's C Dot
if you want the three dots put an S at
the end backslash C Dots so when I
compile this those three dots should be
vertically Centered for our next command
we're going to put
all of this stuff together
and give the definition of a Riemann sum
using a definite integral
so let's open Math mode and the first
thing I want to type is the definite
integral of f of x
from A to B
so we're going to do display Style
open curly brackets I'm going to go
ahead and end them and end the math mode
and then just type in between those
brackets
so we're starting with an integral so
backslash int underscore and then a
carrot B my function will just be f of x
and then to insert a space here
backslash comma DX equals let's compile
just make sure we don't have any errors
to this point and everything looks the
way we expect okay with the integral
from a to b f of x DX is equal to now we
want the limit as n approaches Infinity
so backslash Lim I want to use backslash
limits so that the X approaches Infinity
part appears underneath the Lim
so underscore
curly brackets X
and then to get the arrow backslash 2 to
Infinity backslash i n f t y
closing curly brackets so that should
say the limit as X goes to Infinity
let's compile
make sure we're doing everything
correctly that looks good
let's put my cursor back in front of the
last curly bracket because we still want
to be working inside of display style
now I want the sum as K goes from 1 to n
so backslash s-u-m backslash limits
underscore
and I want k equals 1 on the bottom so
in curly brackets k equals one close
that
carrot on the top I just want n the
curly brackets are optional since it's a
single character so let's make sure we
have our sum
displaying correctly good now we want to
take the sum of f of x sub K so X
underscore K and I don't think I need to
expand the parentheses we can see what
it looks like when we type set it
times Delta X now this is optional but
I'm going to go ahead and put the dot to
indicate multiplication so backslash C
dot that will be a single dot centered
vertically and I'm multiplying that by
Delta X now to get the Delta symbol
for those Greek letters it's backslash
and the name of the letter but if I just
type
all lowercase Delta
X I'm going to get the lowercase Greek
letter so let's see what happens there
okay so I've got my f of x sub K the
parentheses look fine I don't need to
expand them I've got my DOT and that is
not what I wanted to see for Delta X so
the Delta symbol the triangle is
actually the capital letter in the Greek
alphabet so we're just going to go back
and instead of lowercase T it's
backslash Delta with an uppercase d
and pile that again
and now I have my Delta X we have one
last thing to look at that you might run
into
in calculus notation and that is vectors
so to get the vector symbol it's simply
backslash v e c
and then in curly brackets what you want
to put the symbol over so I'm going to
call this vector v
ector V
is equal to and let's do the IJ notation
so we have our first component V sub 1
times Vector I so backslash v e c Vector
I plus v sub 2
so V underscore 2 times Vector J so
backslash v e c
and J in the curly brackets and that is
equal to if we want to write this in
component form
I like to use angular brackets
so it would be for the left angular
bracket it's backslash l
angle and that's going to insert the
bracket so now we need our first
component V sub 1
comma
our second component
V sub 2
and then we want the closing bracket the
right angular bracket so backslash r
angle and that should do it let's close
math mode compile and see how that looks
and I forgot to
put two backslashes earlier to give
myself a little more vertical spacing
okay that looks good so vector v equals
V1 times Vector I plus v sub 2 times
Vector J we're in component form just V1
comma V2 in the angular brackets and
that concludes this tutorial on calculus
notation